Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber es ist ein bisschen schwer.
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber es ist ein bisschen schwer. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber es ist ein bisschen schwer.
Die meisten werden das einwandfrei identifizieren können, wenn kurz nach der Ankündigung, dass es sich um 22 Uhr ein Blue Moon handelt auf Fritz, ein saftiges Tastaturklacken kommt, eines von diesen alten Tastaturklackigen, sowas wo so ein fettes Return dahinter ist und dann von Kraftwerk der Song Nummer ertönt, dann wissen natürlich die meisten schon, ach, das kann doch nur das Chaos Radio sein, dann wird ganz kurz im Kalender nachgeschlagen. Richtig, es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat und damit ist das dann auch endgültig bestätigt. Es befinden sich Chaos-Radioten sozusagen bei Radio Fritz im Studio und das sind in diesem Fall heute der Felix und der Frank. Hallo, ihr zwei.
Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Max von Malodki und ich natürlich sofort mit einer Frage auf der Zunge, denn ich bin zwar jemand, der sich so, sagen wir mal, zu 50 Prozent auch im freundschaftlichen Bereich mit Multimedia auseinandersetzt, aber es gibt dann doch Themen, wo Abkürzungen vorkommen, wo auch ich dann erst mal so sage, ja, was ist das denn?
Zum Beispiel TCPA.
Das soll heute unser Thema zumindest erst mal antreiben. Und da gebe ich einfach mal an euch ab, Jungs, denn was ist TCPA überhaupt?
Ja, die TCPA ist die Trusted Computing Platform Alliance. Das ist ein Zusammenschluss, ein Konsortium von inzwischen über 170 Computerhersteller, und zwar Hardware sowie Software. Gründungsmitglieder sind Microsoft, Intel, IBM, Compaq und HP. Inzwischen sind aber auch alle anderen, also Intuitive, so Leute wie NVIDIA, also auch Grafikkarten und Azobe und alle möglichen Softwarehersteller eben auch. Das Ziel von der TCPA ist die Definition von einer Computerplattform, mit der man Vertrauensverhältnisse ausdrücken und tatsächlich auch erzwingen kann. Konkret geht es darum, dass in dem Computer ein Hardware-Element drin sein soll, was mit Verschlüsselung-Methoden feststellen kann, ob ein Stück Software okay ist. Das heißt, es gibt eine Prüfstumme über die Software und die Hardware kann dann sehen, ist das die, die vom Hersteller ausgeliefert wurde.
Das heißt, das, was ich mir als der User, der möglicherweise, kann ich jetzt natürlich immer nur sagen, sich sein Windows immer mal schön kopiert hat, so zu Kinderzeiten schon, oder sich irgendwelche Spiele rippt oder irgendwelche Musikfiles runterholt, dem soll damit quasi mit diesem kleinen abkürzungswörtlichen TCPA ein Ende gesetzt werden.
Also, worum es geht, ist sozusagen die Entlösung der Kopierschutzfrage und die Entlösung der Frage, kann man Software kopieren oder kann man Software nicht kopieren? Microsoft, Intel und die anderen Gründungsmitglieder der TCPA haben sich da zusammengeschlossen, um dieses Problem vor allem mal aus der Welt zu schaffen, dass diese User ständig dieses Zeug kopieren, ohne dass sie dafür bezahlen. Und man hört ja immer diese Jammer-Schreie von der Business Software Alliance, die in Deutschland ja die Mafia der Softwareindustrie ist, was irgendwie den Kampf gegen Raubkopier betrifft. Und die sind da doch sehr große Freunde von diesen TCPA.
Was man schon so ein bisschen rausholen konnte bei diesen ganzen Herstellern, die da aufgeführt wurden, von dir Felix, da kommt einem automatisch das Wort Trust in den Sinn. Und das kommt in dem Wort TCPA natürlich auch wieder vor. Es heißt nämlich, um eine Trusted Computing Platform Alliance. Da kommt dann auch das Wort Trusted vor, wenn sie es auch nicht so gewollt haben, könnte man sagen.
Ja, also Trust ist natürlich eigentlich nicht im Sinne von Cartel gemeint an der Stelle, aber wir werden später schon darauf kommen, dass das durchaus assoziierbar ist. Tatsächlich geht es nicht nur um Raubkopien, es geht auch um Content, in weiterer Sinne wie zum Beispiel Filme. Ja, also auch ein Stichwort, was häufig im Zusammenhang mit TCPA fällt, ist Hollywood. Aber jetzt, was wir hier in dieser Sendung erzählen werden, basiert zu großen Teilen nicht auf Verlautbarung von der TCPA, sondern auf zwischen den Zeilen reden und auf Analysen, was man mit der Technologie machen könnte, wenn sie da wäre. Also wir wollen jetzt nicht sagen, dass Microsoft das tatsächlich alles so geplant hat, wie wir es jetzt hier in unseren Fantasien ausmalen werden, aber das sind durchaus reale Möglichkeiten, die wichtig und weitgreifend genug sind, dass man da frühzeitig drüber nachdenken muss.
Also der schöne deutsche Begriff Technologiefolgenabschätzung, der greift da wieder mal.
Wie ist das denn abgekürzt im Vergleich zu TCPA?
Tfabgunk wahrscheinlich.
Ich musste mal das Forschungsministerium fragen, die haben da bestimmt eine Abkürzung für.
Also wenn ihr eine andere Abkürzung braucht, also nicht hier direkt anrufen möchtet, dann könnt ihr zum Beispiel abkürzen per Mail, wenn ihr an der Sendung teilnehmen möchtet. Für allgemeine Anfragen, was das Chaos Radio anbelangt und den Chaos Computer Club empfehlen, wir folgen die E-Mail-Adresse chaosradio.ccc.de. Da also aber bitte nicht zum Sendungsthema heute Abend was sagen möchten, wenn ihr das möchtet, dann an 78 als Zahl geschrieben, at chaosradio.ccc.de schreiben. Wenn ihr vielleicht ein bisschen ausführlicher so aus dem hohlen Bauch oder so was schreiben möchtet und solche Menschen, das möchte ich jetzt aber nicht sagen, weil meine Stimme ist vielleicht nicht so ganz, dann könnt ihr da eine Mail hinschreiben. Und vielleicht, wenn ihr euch das alles nicht merken könnt und euch das zu viele E-Mail-Adressen sind, http://chaosradio.ccc.de ist die Web-Adresse, um euch das alles noch mal durchzulesen. Und ihr könnt natürlich anrufen unter 0331 77 97 1 1 0. Und ist uns das genug für den Einstieg in TCPA oder wollen wir noch mal weiter ausholen, bevor wir jetzt einfach dazu schreiten, die Menschen in Berlin und Brandenburg zu fragen, ob sie das überhaupt wollen?
Ich denke, wir sollten vielleicht noch ein, zwei Worte dazu verlieren, was da technologisch eigentlich passiert.
Ja, also die TCPA sollte ursprünglich nur sicherstellen, dass die Hersteller garantieren können mit ihrer Software, dass sie auf unmanipulierten Rechnern läuft. Das war die Grundidee vor mehreren Jahren. Die Idee ist auch schon relativ alt. Und später ist es dann erweitert worden um einen Schlüssel im Computer, sodass auch die Software erkennen kann, ob andere nicht vertrauenswürdige Software läuft. Und die Konnotation mit den Raubkopien ist erst später dazu gekommen. Aber konkret stellt sich heute die Frage, ist es uns überhaupt wichtig, mit unseren Rechnern Sachen kopieren zu können? Stört uns das, wenn wir mit Kopierschutz gehindert werden sollen, unsere CD einmal fürs Auto zu kopieren oder für einen Freund oder für einen Nachbarn?
Genau, das ist auch die Frage, die wir vielleicht so an die Hörer richten wollen. Wie wichtig ist euch eigentlich, dass Filme und Musik usw. kopieren können? Und könntet ihr darauf verzichten? Wäre das irgendwie eine Option für euch? Stört euch dieser Kopierschutz auf den CDs? Das würden wir gerne wissen.
0331 77 97 91 10, die Telefonnummer. Würdet ihr sagen, das ist mir eigentlich leicht wegschnuppe, ob ich da noch was kopieren kann oder nicht, weil ich koffe mir im Endeffekt sowieso alles. Ich habe ja Kohle, besonders in Zeiten der Rezession, so wie jetzt. Ich meine, das wäre auch kein Arbeitslosen in Deutschland. Oder sagt ihr, nee, das finde ich nicht so toll, dass die sich das jetzt überlegen und auf einmal sagen, hey, also Kopierschutz würde ich nicht so gerne sehen. 0331 77 97 91 10, die Telefonnummer. Und ihr könnt euch direkt hier uns zu uns ins Studio stellen lassen und mit uns darüber diskutieren. Egal, ob ihr jetzt die high level Inside Informationen habt und sagt, hey, TCPA finde ich aufgrund der und der Tatsache scheiße. Oder ob ihr einfach sagt, grundsätzlich gefällt mir das nicht, was die da vorhaben. Aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, weil das war vorhin so ein bisschen knapp ab und für jemanden, der sich nicht damit auskennt, was bedeutet das überhaupt, dieses mit Signieren und Hardware auf Software abdongeln, fongeln, mongeln und so, was passiert da?
Was verstellen die sich genau vor?
Ich meine, ich kaufe diesen Computer dann im Geschäft, nehmen wir mal an, dass gäbe es. Ich gehe in den Laden rein und sage, ich hätte gerne einen TCPA Computer und dann geben die mir einen.
Und was ist ab da anders als sonst?
Na die eigentliche Idee ist, dass der Benutzer nicht mehr die höchsten Zugriffsmöglichkeiten auf seinem Rechner hat, sondern bisher ist es so, ich installiere mir Windows, lock mich als Administrator ein, dann kann ich mit dem Rechner alles machen. Ich kann unter anderem auch einen Debugger installieren und kann Trainer benutzen, um Spiele zu bescheißen oder ich kann einen Grunde, was ich mache, was ich will, kann meine Movies kopieren, kann die Platte formatieren und in Zukunft soll es eben eine Instanz zwischen dem Rechner und der Hardware geben und dem User. Das heißt, dass der User zwar sagen kann, ich möchte jetzt dieses und jenes machen, aber der Rechner kann entscheiden, ob das überhaupt erlaubt ist. Es soll also eine Hardware Instanz im Computer geben, die sagen kann, diese Aktion ist jetzt verboten.
Super, das heißt, ich versuche dann irgendwas zu installieren und dann sagt der Rechner, man, dafür bist du zu klein. Und dann das nächste Programm, dafür bist du zu dumm. Nein, dafür bist du zu... So soll das dann gehen?
Ja, das soll nicht mit Biometrie funktionieren. Also deine persönlichen Merkmale sind da nicht drin. Aber letztendlich ist das durchaus die zentrale Frage bei TCPA, wer eigentlich konkret jetzt entscheidet, wer was darf und wer nicht. Wir werden später ein paar Szenarien aufmalen, was konkret wir als problematisch betrachten. Aber die Grundidee ist zum Beispiel, dass wenn ich mir eine DVD geliehen habe und spiele die jetzt ab mit meinem Player, dass dann der Player erkennen kann, es läuft eine Software, die nicht von der TCPA-Autorität unterstützt wird. Sagen wir mal, eine Kopierapplikation. Das ist das Szenario, was von Hollywood gewünscht wird, dass der DVD-Player die Software erkennen kann, ob da ein Programm im Hintergrund läuft, was nicht zu Windows gehört und was möglicherweise eben Audio-Signale abgreift und irgendwo hin speichert. Und dann kann der Player sagen, ok, ich weigere mich, hier die DVD abzuspielen. Also das ist die Idee im Grunde, dass die Software die Möglichkeit in die Hand gegeben bekommen soll, zu sagen, das darf ich jetzt nicht.
Und die Software, die das dann umgehen würde, also die meinetwegen nicht Windows-mäßig Media Player ist, die würde da auch nicht funktionieren. Das heißt, wenn ich mir irgendeinen Freeware-Player runterlade, der würde genauso an der Hardware-Komponente scheitern.
Genau, die Idee ist halt genau das zu verhindern, dass man halt Software auf dem Gerät ausführen kann, wenn es sich in einem Modus befindet, in dem man zum Beispiel halt diesen Windows-Player benutzen kann. Also es gibt halt verschiedene Modi. Es gibt halt den Trusted-Modus und den Untrusted-Modus. An dem Augenblick, wo das Gerät halt am Trusted-Modus ist, verhindert es halt, dass nicht vertrauenswürdige Software nach dem Begriff von Microsoft überhaupt gestartet werden kann. So, das geht halt so weit, dass wenn TCPA vollständig implementiert ist, dann verhindert es auch, dass nicht vertrauenswürdige Betriebssysteme auf diesem Computer gebootet werden können.
Also auch wenn ich in eine CD reinschiebe oder so, das geht dann halt nicht. Das ist nicht... Das BIOS ist schon Teil von dem TCPA. Das BIOS erkennt, beim Booten ist das überhaupt Windows. Auf Deutsch ist das erlaubt. Und wenn ich da, sag ich mal, Linux booten möchte, dann kann der Firmenadministrator über TCPA eingestellt haben. Darf nicht. Und dann funktioniert es eben auch, wenn ich eine CD eingelegt habe.
Aber wenn ich das jetzt heraus höre mit Administrator und so weiter, ist das dann was, was ich als normaler User im Endeffekt noch verhindern kann, indem ich das in diesem sogenannten untrusted Modus fahre, das Ganze, und dann sage ich mir scheißegal.
Ja, dann ist es aber so, dass du möglicherweise Content, den du abspielen möchtest, z.B. eine DVD, einfach im untrusted Modus schlecht gar nicht abspielen kannst.
Also die Daten sind auch verschlüsselt. Die Daten sind verschlüsselt und das Programm, sag ich mal, der DVD-Player, der das jetzt abspielen möchte, der geht zur Hardware und sagt, ich bin der vertrauenswürdige DVD-Player, prüfe mal meine Signatur nach. Dann guckt sich die Hardware den DVD-Player an, also die Software, sagt, okay, ist in meiner Datenbank drin. Also konkret soll das über eine Liste laufen, die eben über Internet auch abgedettet wird. Und dann kann die Hardware dem DVD-Player sagen, okay, dir vertraue ich, hier ist der Schlüssel. Und der ist eben computerspezifisch. Das heißt, die Idee ist eben, dass die Daten auch auf der Festplatte verschlüsselt liegen. Und dass ich auch, wenn ich im Anschluss mit nur das Linux boot und eigentlich die Datei lesen kann physikalisch, dass ich die dann eben trotzdem nicht abspielen kann.
Wahnsinn. Das heißt, wenn ich dann keinen Internetanschluss habe, kann ich meinen Rechner sowieso nicht benutzen. Das wird ja, das gefällt ja.
Also so konkret haben die das noch nicht gesagt, aber das ist eine der Sachen, die im Grunde aus den Sachen folgt, die bisher veröffentlicht wurden.
Und was ist mit Leuten, die jetzt aus professionellen Gründen irgendwas kopieren müssen?
Das ist auch eine interessante Frage, wie das konkret funktionieren soll.
Wie sie dann halt die technische Lösung für Leute, die Content kreieren, also die halt Filme machen oder Musik machen und so weiter und so fort machen. Wie sie das Problem für die Leute lösen. Dazu haben sie sich noch nicht so richtig ausgelassen. Sie sagen zwar nur, es wird da keine Beschränkungen geben, nur wie sie es dann technisch realisieren wollen, ist schon interessant.
Na ja, fast noch interessanter ist ja, wie Programmierer eigentlich solche Software entwickeln sollen. Denn während ich sie entwickel, ändert sich die Software im Minutentakt. Ja, weil ich ändere hier was, ändere da was. Das heißt, die kann gar nicht signiert sein. Und indem man eigentlich entwickelt jetzt eine Software wie ein DVD-Player, dann kann ich sozusagen jedes Mal einen Tag warten, bis das dann durch Microsoft durch ist und wir es unterschrieben haben oder so. Also das ist alles noch nicht ganz klar, die Details. Im Grunde ist es im Moment erstmal eine Marketingkampagne. Und es gibt, also was es gibt, ist eine Spezifikation für den Hardware-Teil, was der können soll. Aber da kann man halt relativ weitreichende Sachen mit implementieren. Das heißt, was wir jetzt hier an die Wand malen, sind Sachen, auf die möglicherweise auch Microsoft noch nicht gekommen ist oder Intel.
Oder die sie zumindest nicht zugeben wollen.
Genau, oder die sie halt nicht zugeben wollen. Das kann man alles nicht sagen. Wir würden uns auch nicht wirklich ärgern, wenn hier jetzt der Pressesprecher von Microsoft anrief und uns die Wahrheit erzählt.
Der schläft schon. Microsoft-Mitarbeiter müssen um 21.45 Uhr im Bettchen liegen.
Gutes Timing für unsere Sendung.
Ja, aber ihr könnt hier anrufen. Alle anderen aus Berlin-Brandenburg, außer dem Microsoft-Pressesprecher 0331 70 97 110, die Nummer vom Chaosradio heute Abend im Studio Felix, Frank und meine Persönlichkeit Max. Und am Telefon ist der Pascal. Hallo Pascal. Abend.
Hallo zusammen. Das ist ja eine traurige Geschichte mit dem Fritz-Chip und ähnlichem.
Genau, das habe ich noch gar nicht erwähnt. Der Chip, also die Hardware-Implementierung, hat leider den Namen Fritz-Chip, das hat natürlich nichts mit diesem Sender zu tun.
Überhaupt nichts.
Und auch nicht mit öffentlich-rechtlichen Gebühren.
Aber es ist schon so ein bisschen.
Aber es ist mit Armaum in Berlin. Leider mit dem kranken Hirn aus den USA, der die Sache entwickelt hat.
Du bist ja offensichtlich jemand, der sich da schon etwas tiefgehender auskennt. Was meinst du denn dann, wenn du jetzt so ein Urteil darüber fällen müsstest? Fällt das gut oder schlecht aus?
Ich finde das, sage ich mal, ganz böse gesagt. In Anführungszeichen gut für die Linux-Community. Weil ich glaube nicht, dass sich jeder HP Linux kaufen wird. Und die neueste Hardware muss ich auch nicht ständig hier im Raum stehen haben.
Intel nur noch Pentium, Smith, TCPA und AMD nur noch Atlant, Smith, TCPA produziert. Also die Roadmaps sehen vor, dass es ab Mitte 2004 nur noch TCPA, CPUs geben wird.
Aber bis dahin kann ich mir ein schönes Multiprocessing Board zusammenschustern.
Nur dann? Ich meine also, wie oft decktest du so deinen Rechner ab, so hardwaremäßig? Normal?
Im Normalfall, der hier steht jetzt seit zwei Jahren das Ding. Ab und zu wird nachgerüstet, aber nicht unbedingt abgekreidet.
Na gut, aber das heißt also, alle drei bis vier Jahre tauscht du schon mal damit CPU aus? Das heißt also, dass du spätestens 2007 dann auch davon betroffen bist?
Also man kann ja vielleicht sagen, die Situation bei der Berliner Polizei ist ja wohl so ähnlich, dass die auch irgendwann gesagt haben, ok, wir haben jetzt halt unsere VW Busse und da wird auch nichts Neues kommen und die kaufen inzwischen per eBay in Südamerika ein, weil es einfach keine Teile mehr gibt. Also klar, die Kopf-in-Sand-Technik haben wir uns auch überlegt, so können wir einfach sagen, ok, das Problem ignorieren wir und installieren jetzt eben, das ist der letzte Rechner, den ich kaufe. Ja, aber so langfristig ist das nicht wirklich tragfähig, das Konzept. Weil irgendwann gehen halt doch mal was kaputt und dann kann ich jetzt natürlich sagen, ok, ich kauf jetzt halt 10 aktuelle Prozessoren, dann hält das vielleicht noch 5 Jahre länger.
Aber...
Aber ich mein, bevor ich mir so einen TCPA abgesägnenen Chip hier kaufe, dass das Geld echt zum Fenster rausknalle, da investiere ich lieber in öffentliche CPUs und Ähnliches.
Jetzt mal eine Frage, nur so von meiner Pseudo-leihenhaften Seite. Was für ein Interesse haben Hardware-Hersteller daran, Microsoft in dem Punkt in die Hände zu spielen, dass sie ab einem bestimmten Punkt nur noch diese Prozessoren zum Beispiel produzieren? Weil, nehmen wir es mal wirklich bei der Hand, der Hauptgrund, warum sich Leute diese Computer kaufen, ist doch oft, dass sie damit zumindest mal zu 50 Prozent Musik kopieren möchten und halt noch ihre Dokumente machen möchten und so. Aber so wichtig ist das alles nicht, ich denke, das hat doch den Boom ausgelöst, die wissen doch auch, dass sie das dann so damit zurückschrauben oder nicht?
Das kann ich doch auch mit einem zwei Jahren alten Maschine hier machen, muss sie kopieren und Texte schreiben.
Klar, also dein Grund, keine Frage, muss ich ehrlich sagen, d'accord Pascal, aber was ist mit den Herstellern, wieso gehen die dieses Risiko ein?
Na ja, weil sie natürlich...
Microsoft-kompatibel, wollen die doch nur sein.
Na ja, nee, die Hoffnung der Hersteller ist natürlich, dass sie auf diese Art und Weise eine neue Updatewelle mit reiten kann, wenn halt Microsoft hingeht...
Wenn Paladium ausstößt.
Genau, wenn Microsoft hingeht und halt Paladium, was sozusagen der Software-Tel von TCPA ist, in seinem Betriebssystem implementiert und in seinen Office-Applikationen und so weiter und sofort implementiert, was dann halt irgendwann dazu führt, dass man das neue Windows und das neue Office nur noch auf einer neuen Hardware benutzen kann, dann ist klar, dass die Leute irgendwann upgraden müssen. Und das...
Da steht ja Microsoft vor dem nächsten Problem, wenn die das tatsächlich durchziehen, die Geschichte, dann können sie ja Lizenzgeführenden Lucky Green bezahlen oder wie der heißt, in den USA.
Ja, mit dem telefonieren wir gleich nachher und können mal hören, was er dazu meint.
Ich mein, der ist dann am Schluss reicher als Billy Boy.
Also der Punkt ist, man kann sich ja zum Beispiel ansehen, was AMD zum letzten Quartal der US-Börsenaufsicht gesagt hat, da muss man als US-Aktiengesellschaft weitrückende Sachen eben Analysen publizieren, wie viel Geld man gemacht hat und was man eben für die größten Gefahren in der Zukunft hält. Und AMD hat gesagt, die größte Gefahr, die sie überhaupt sehen, ist, dass Windows nicht auf ihren neuen Opteron-Prozessoren läuft. Ja, wenn das passiert, sind sie tot, haben sie gesagt. Und so geht das viel in Hardware-Hersteller. Man kann sich schon sehen, dass sich heute einfach Boards mit USB 2.0 nicht drauf, wo es noch echt viele voran im Einzelhandel gibt, verkaufen sich wie bleierne Enten überhaupt nicht. Und nicht, weil irgendjemand USB 2.0 braucht, die kann man irgendwie an zwei Händen abzählen, die Leute in Deutschland die USB 2.0 brauchen, aber einfach weil die Leute denken, oh neu, das will ich haben. Und es ist ja so, dass man kann ja schon die ersten Rechner mit TCPA Hardware kaufen, das sind Kinkpads von IBM und da steht dann dran, ja zusätzlich als Option Security Feature. Und dann denkt sich der durchschnittliche Computerbild-Leser eben, oh toll. Genau und das ist eben der Grund.
In welcher Fallklinik er tritt, merkt er gar nicht.
Richtig. Also das ist im Grunde die eigentliche Frage, werden die Leute alle glauben, dass das für sie gut ist? Oder können wir heute genügend Aufklärung betreiben, um das Gegenteil zu bewirken?
Ich hoffe wir kriegen das Gegenteil hin.
Aber ganz ernst, habt ihr schon mal in irgendeinem Medium gelesen, dass TCPA gut ist? Ich meine wahrscheinlich liest man noch einfach die falschen Medien, wenn man erst mal in einer bestimmten Gruppe unterwegs ist, aber...
Ich denke die Computerbild schreibt bestimmt, dass TCPA gut ist.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob die überhaupt schon was dazu geschrieben haben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das schon kennen, gut ist eine andere Frage. Nein, ähm...
Na die werden dann die Hitzeentwicklung von dem Chip prüfen. Die werden dann die Hitzeentwicklung und Übertaktbarkeit von dem Chip testen.
Richtig, richtig. Ähm, und was ich auch noch ein bisschen problematisch sehe, sind die kleineren Softwarehersteller, die Hobbyprogrammierer. Die können sich doch gar nicht diese Signierung bei Microsoft leisten auf Dauer.
Die wird am Anfang kostenlos sein. Das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen, Microsoft hat 40 Milliarden Dollar auf Tasche. Die können das ein paar Jahre betreiben, ohne irgendwie ein Problem damit zu haben. Und irgendwann kostet das Geld, aber das kann man ja nicht Microsoft anlassen, dass sie da nicht auf Jahre Verlust mitmachen. Und da wird dann selbst die Kartellrichterin, die ihnen gerade da weitgehend freie Hand gegeben hat, die wird es nicht mal begründen können, da ein Verfahren einzuleiten, wenn Microsoft aufhört, das zu sponsoren. Also das ist leider relativ klar, wie man sowas am Markt einführt.
Jetzt sag doch mal, weil ihr euch da ja wirklich auch auskennt, wie viel davon ist als softe Variante schon in XP enthalten, weil man ja auch dieses Ding kennt nach dem Motto, wenn ich das dritte Mal Hardware auswechsel bei XP oder ähnliches, dann habe ich bestimmte Keys einzugeben oder so. Ist es nicht schon so zum Teil, dass das da ähnlich ist?
Ja, in Windows XP sind sozusagen die Softwarevarianten implementiert. Das heißt also, was sie gerne wollen, nur halt noch nicht richtig sicher. Also man kann es bei XP halt noch relativ problemlos alles umgehen und einschränken und in seiner Firewall rauskonfigurieren und so weiter und so fort. Das wird dann halt irgendwann nicht mehr gehen, wenn es halt Hardware unterstützt ist.
Aber nehmen wir mal das Beispiel Xbox.
Viele werden diese Spielekonsole ja kennen und dieses Ding war auf dem Markt und ungefähr zwei Tage hieß es, das ist das sicherste, was man sich vorstellen kann. Da ist eine Festplatte drin, da wird verschlüsselt. Also kann man keine fremden Festplatten einbauen, fremde Daten drauf spielen. Man kann da keine DVDs, die eben halt nicht in der Region hergestellt worden sind. Und dann dauerte das glaube ich einen Monat oder zwei und dann war die Sache schon mit drei Chips gleichzeitig, also wirklich die auf dem Markt waren, überbrückt. Das heißt, ich konnte sogar eine andere Festplatte einbauen, wenn ich wollte. Inwiefern interessiert mich dann Hardware denn noch?
Hast du mitbekommen, was jetzt letzte Woche passierte mit dem Xbox Live? Das sind nämlich die User, die halt genau diese Modchips verbaut haben in ihren Systemen halt einfach bei Xbox Live, also dem Gaming-Netzwerk von Microsoft nicht mehr teilnehmen können. Das ist halt tatsächlich genau das, was dir dann halt auch passiert. Wenn du halt Software auf deinem Computer hast, die halt nicht trusted ist oder nicht gewünscht ist, dann kommst du halt einfach in diese Gaming-Netzwerke nicht mehr rein, wie die halt auch von Microsoft dringen.
Nee, das ist ja sogar so, dass Microsoft die Leute gebannt hat, die ein Modchip drin hatten. Das heißt, wenn die den rausgenommen haben, sind die mit ihrer alten ID nicht mehr reingekommen. Ja, das heißt, man musste da schon größere Eingriffe machen, um überhaupt wieder teilnehmen zu können. Und Microsoft kann es egal sein, weil im Moment machen die massiv Verlust mit ihrer Xbox. Also ob die da Kunden vergraulen oder nicht, interessiert die genau überhaupt nicht. Sondern man kann noch sagen, das machen die nur, um Sony mal so richtig zu ärgern.
Aber was ich viel interessanter finde, ist, dass Linux bereits auf der Xbox recht gut läuft.
Ja gut, also klar, Linux darauf zum Spielen zu kriegen, ist zwar ein schöner Stunt, aber wenn man sich halt mal anguckt, wie die Marktkräfte aussehen, dann können wir nicht ernsthaft damit rechnen, dass Linux auch irgendwie in Zeiten von TCPA einen Marktanteil von, sagen wir mal, über 20 Prozent haben wird. Und insofern ist es schon so, dass tatsächlich der Großteil der User, die die normales Renus verwenden, ziemlich davon betroffen sein werden. Das Problem ist halt einfach, man kann sich da auf den Kopf stellen, wie man will, Linux ist einfach nicht für jeden so.
Aber wenn ich mir die heutigen Installationsroutinen von den Großen anschaue, sei es Red Hat, Debian, nein, nicht Debian, die Franzosen.
Ja, weißt du, ich meine, ich bin da noch ein bisschen hart, ich bin Mac-User, und zwar aus gutem Grund. Und wenn ich mir halt irgendwie dieses Linux angucke, wenn ich da mit einer ganz normalen Konsumerhaltung rangehe, dann muss ich halt einfach sagen, okay, das werde ich irgendwie sicherlich nicht installieren, wenn ich damit irgendwie arbeiten will, wenn ich damit spielen will, gut und gerne. Aber zum Arbeiten ist es mir halt einfach noch ein wenig zu feature-arm.
Ja, na gut, aber wir müssen ja keine heiligen Kriege losdrehen.
Lass uns den Operating Systems voran alle mal fechten. Aber wie gesagt, ich denke, schön, dass es Linens gibt, aber inwieweit es uns irgendwie gegen die CPA helfen wird, steht noch an den Sternen.
Na ja, ein bisschen was kann man dazu sagen.
Ich denke eben, dass Microsoft dann trotz dem bisschen zu verhängnis werden kann, wenn es dann soweit sein soll. Wenn es das tatsächlich durchzieht.
Ich glaube, die sind dabei Pascal. Hoffen wir mal, dass das nicht ein Wunschraum bleibt, was wir uns so vorstellen. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Nix zu danken.
Ach Mensch, ihr seid immer so pessimistisch, Jungs. Ihr macht einen ganz fertig.
Die Computer Bild hat übrigens noch nicht so Paladium oder TCPA auf ihren Seiten.
Es würde mich mal interessieren, ob es viele von euch gibt, die die lesen, aber vielleicht sind jetzt doch der eine oder andere dabei. Da stehen ja unten immer so kleine Abkürzungen, wie man das ausspricht und was das denn überhaupt ist.
Und was dann dabei TCPA so steht. Ganz tolle Sache. Schönes Ding.
Wunderbar. Die Computer Bild operiert ja auch so ein bisschen so. Ich meine, einerseits ist das sehr, sehr userfreundlich. Andererseits ist das natürlich auch beschiss. Die greifen im Grunde immer erst das auf, was wirklich auf einer breiten Basis vorhanden ist. Das heißt, wenn dann so 70% das alles irgendwie haben, dann gehen die mal drauf ein. Aber dann ist es leider auch zu spät.
Vor allem sagen sie dann, oh, der große Hit, der mega erfolgt. Das ist natürlich keine große Voraussage mehr, wenn 50% das schon einsetzen.
Das ist auch egal. Das stimmt alles ganz sicher.
Es soll ja nicht hier um Computerbild gehen, sondern eigentlich geht es ja um TCPA.
Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0377 77 91 10 und euch am Chaos Radio Blue Moon beteiligen, hier auf Fritz im Studio Felix und Frank und Max. Und wir möchten die Fragen einfach noch mal weiter in einem Raum stehen lassen. Wie wichtig ist euch das, dass ihr bestimmen könnt, was ihr an euren Rechner einfach so einbaut? Und wir haben ja halt dieses kleine Auseinander pflücken oder auch nicht, bzw. was ihr für Inhalte auf eurem Rechner abspielt, kopiert, weiterleitet, mal auf CD runter brennt oder demnächst auch auf DVD und dann euren Kumpel gibt. Wie wichtig ist euch das? Würdet ihr das behalten wollen? Oder ist euch das Schnuppe? Und freut ihr euch schon, ob das neue TCPA-Palladium von Microsoft, was vielleicht irgendwann mal ansteht, am Telefon, ist der Simon aus Berlin. Hallo Simon.
Ja, also ich bin der Meinung, als wenn dann dieses TCPA dann auf den Markt kommt, dann gibt es bestimmt auch Leute, die dann so ein Programm irgendwie entwickeln, um das zu umgehen.
Ja gut, also es ist so, dass die ersten Serien von TCPA und Palladium werden sicherlich noch brechbar sein. Nur, was wir da halt sehen, ist natürlich eine Evolution. Das heißt also jeder Schritt, der halt da passiert, wird dann halt immer komplexer zu replizieren. Und was Microsoft halt sagt und was Intel auch sagt, ist, dass ihr Ziel ist, nicht es unbrechbar zu machen, sondern es so zu bauen, dass Attacken jeweils immer nur für einen Rechner funktionieren. Das heißt, selbst wenn du in der Lage bist, dafür zu sorgen, dass du zum Beispiel ein Stück Software, was irgendwie eigentlich nicht lizenziert ist, für deinen Computer auf deinem Computer laufen zu lassen, dass du dann trotzdem dieses Stück Software nicht auf andere Computer rüber bekommst. Also diese Nicht-Replizierbarkeit von Angriffen ist das Kernziel des Designs dabei. Weil sie natürlich genau wissen, dass jeder Architektur irgendwie angreifbar ist. Das heißt, ich kann im Zweifel immer irgendwie an den Memory-Bus gehen oder den Chip irgendwie anbohren oder was auch immer. Und vermutlich würde es auch in den ersten Generationen relativ einfach gehen, aber es wird dann halt immer schwieriger werden, je weiter die Technologie fortschreitet. Also wenn man sich heute so moderne Elektronik anguckt, da ist es zum Beispiel, den Memory-Bus anzuzapfen auf so einer 6-lagigen Leiterplatte, das ist schon nicht mehr so ganz trivial, selbst wenn man die nötigen Tools dafür hat. Also insofern, der Optimismus in allen Ehren, aber an dieser Stelle kann es durchaus sein, dass man sich dann doch mal irrt.
Wenn wir jetzt auch gucken, es gibt ja im Internet auch Millionen Sachen, die man downloaden kann, ob das TCPA das auch anerkennen würde, die ganzen Downloads?
Wenn sie von Microsoft signiert sind, schon. Also letztendlich wird das das grundlegende Detail sein, was dann das Überleben von Softwarefirmen herstellt. Wenn die in der Lage sind, ihre Software schnell genug signieren zu lassen. Und insbesondere heißt es auch, wenn Microsoft sich bei einem Hersteller, den sie nicht mögen, ein bisschen Zeit lässt, mit dem signieren kann, es durchaus den wirtschaftlichen Tod bedeuten. Also irgendwelche Shareware aus dem Netz zu signieren, das wird Microsoft vielleicht am Anfang kostenlos machen. Aber irgendwann wird das Geld kosten. Das kann man ganz gut an VeriSign sehen. Die sind da gegründet worden als kleine Tochter von RSA Security. Das sind die Erfinder von dem RSA Algorithmus. Und die haben am Anfang eben gedacht, wir müssen hier Infrastruktur schaffen, haben eine Firma gemacht. Die ruft im Grunde ein bisschen Software auf. Da kriegt man dann Key für, das sind ein paar Bits. Da tun die genau gar nichts für, das ist voll automatisiert. Und die haben inzwischen so viel Kohle gemacht, dass sie den Betreiber von den US DNS Service kaufen konnten, was im Grunde auch eine Gelddruckmaschine ist. Also man kann sehen, auch mit so kleinen Details in der Infrastruktur kann man enorm Kohle schäfeln.
Simon, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Tschüss. Das ist eigentlich ganz so traurig.
Der Frank und der Felix sind schon ganz schön gemein. Ich hör das doch an deiner Stimme. Ja, tschüss, dann... Weil ich fühl mich auch schon so. Felix und Frank immer deinen Optimismus in allen Ähren, aber es sieht schon unglaublich scheiße aus. So hört sich das nämlich immer an. Danke für deinen Anruf. So, und Zeit für Nachrichten, aber da wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht besser aussehen.
Wenn Fritz rundum bälzig, dann 91, 9.
Uhrzeit 22.31 Uhr. Das Wetter nachts wird ziemlich neblig. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 2 bis minus 2 Grad. Morgen ist es dann bedeckt und trügel bei 4 bis 8 Grad. Und zu allem Überfluss gibt es dann ab und zu, aber auch nur ab und zu noch Sprühregen. Die Meldung mit Bastian Berner.
Deutschland will den USA bei einem Angriff auf den Irak Überflug- und Transitrechte gewähren. Bundeskanzler Schröder sagte, eine direkte militärische Unterstützung werde es aber nicht geben. Nur Israel werde aus moralischen Gründen Luftabwehrraketen und Truppentransporter des Typs Fuchs erhalten. Die UNO-Waffeninspektoren haben mit ihren Kontrollen im Irak begonnen. Sie durchsuchten heute zwei Militäranlagen und eine Fabrik in der Umgebung von Bagdad. UNO-Generalsekretär Anand sprach von einem guten Start. Der FDP-Politiker Jürgen Möllemann will aus seiner Partei nicht freiwillig austreten. Er werde sich dem Druck der Parteiführung nicht beugen, sagte Möllemann in mehreren Interviews. Er denkt nach engen Angaben darüber nach, eine neue liberale Partei zu gründen. Die islamistische Vereinigung Khalifatstaat bleibt verboten. Das Bundesverwaltungsgericht bestätigte am Abend eine Entscheidung der Bundesregierung. Nach Ansicht der Richter hat der Verein sowohl gegen die demokratische Grundordnung als auch gegen das Rechtsstaatprinzip und die Achtung der Menschen. Der Menschenwürde verstoßen. Wir haben keine Meldungen, also gute Fahrt.
Gehen wir zu dir oder zu...
Natürlich zu...
Mia. Elektrobank.
Samstag 30. November 21 Uhr Landei Lugau. Herbstzeit ist Konzertzeit.
Fritz. Und ihr hört immer noch das Chaosradio auf. Fritz, die erste halbe Stunde haben wir uns hunter gebracht. Zunächst eigentlich erstmal mit einer Begriffdefinition, nämlich was ist TCPA? Für diejenigen, die jetzt erst einschalten, TCPA. Ich erkläre das doch nicht. Ich bin doch nicht verrückt. Ich habe doch Felix und Frank vom Chaosradio da. Die können das doch viel besser erklären als ich.
TCPA kommt von Microsoft.
Da werden 80% natürlich schon sagen, auch dann könnte das ja böse sein. Richtig, das könnte es.
Ja, es kommt auch von Intel. Also Microsoft sind diesmal nicht allein die Bösen. Und um das ein bisschen historisch in die Relation zu setzen, Intel hat schon mehrere Anläufe gestartet, um innliche Merkmale mal anzutesten. Die haben unter anderem meine Seriennummer in ihren Prozessoren versucht einzubauen, sind massiv unter Druck geraten in der Öffentlichkeit. TCPA, sowas ähnliches geht nun weiter, nämlich, dass die Hardware, der Software sagen kann, diese und jene Aktion ist jetzt nicht erlaubt. Das heißt, der Benutzer hat nicht mehr die oberste Instanz, hat nicht mehr das letzte Wort, wenn es darum geht, welche Programme auf dem Rechner laufen.
Inwiefern ist das eigentlich legal? Weil zum Beispiel, für mich gibt es das kleinere Beispiel. Ich kann das ja mal kurz formulieren, weil es mir jetzt einfach wirklich schon mal passiert ist. Und zwar bin ich leidenschaftlicher Diablo 2 Spieler, Hardcore Classic. Und da ist es so, dass man sich einen sogenannten Map Hack runterladen kann. Da muss man erklären, in diesem Spiel funktioniert das folgendermaßen. Das spielt man und man hat im Grunde auf einer Taste so eine Kartenansicht. Die wird über die normale Spielansicht, wo man oben auf seine kleine Spielfigur geguckt, drüber geblendet. Und nun ist das so, dass dieses Spiel im Netz gespielt wird. So spiele ich es zumindest, man kann es auch zu Hause spielen. Und da ist das dann dementsprechend, weil sehr, sehr viele Leute bei den Servern von Blizzard, das ist die Firma, die das Spiel herstellt, spielen, laggy ist. Laggy bedeutet, da sind da manchmal so kleine Aussetzer. Da bleibt auf einmal die Spielfigur hängen. Nur ist das in dem Spiel ziemlich doof, weil insbesondere wenn man mitten im Gefecht mit irgendwelchen kleinen Monstern aus der Fantasy-Welt steht und dann bleibt dieses Ding hängen, dann macht das einfach nur putz und dann ist die Figur, die man sich über zwei Wochen lang erschaffen hat, futsch. Also nimmt man diesen Map Pack, bei dem man sehen kann, okay, in etwa 50 Meter Entfernung kommt, und das kann man normal nicht sehen, das und das Monster auf mich zu, das könnte mir gefährlich werden. Und Blizzard hat dann einfach mal eine Pressemeldung rausgegeben und die sagt, ey, jeder von euch, der diesen Map Pack benutzt, und das sind ungefähr 30.000, wie wir wissen, werden wir einfach ihre Lizenz sperren. Und das haben die offensichtlich auch durchgezogen.
Mich haben sie bis jetzt noch nicht erwischt, aber ich hab mir gedacht, welches Recht haben die eigentlich mir zu sagen, was ich mit ihrem kleinen Scheißprogramm machen kann?
Und welches Recht haben die, solche Sachen aufzuoktroyieren, mir aufzusetzen?
Das Schöne ist, in Amerika kann sie damit ziemlich viel machen, das sind halt irgendwie diese End-User-License-Agreements, die halt doch irgendwie meistens ziemlich verbrecherische Klauseln enthalten. Und die, soweit ich weiß, in Deutschland auch gar nicht so richtig durchgehen.
Nein, also überhaupt nicht. Es ist so, dass in Deutschland, wenn ich ein Stück Software kaufe, dann kann mir nicht später gesagt werden, die Software darfst du aber nur für so und so einsetzen, sondern das muss mir beim Kauf gesagt werden. Ansonsten ist der Kauf rückgängig zu machen. Also es ist nicht so, dass Microsoft später sagen kann, aber mit Frontpage darfst du nicht auf Webseiten schreiben, dass Microsoft scheiße ist. Und das klingt jetzt vielleicht wie ein Witz, aber das steht ernsthaft in der EULA zu Frontpage drin.
Die EULA? Was ist denn da?
EULA ist das End User License Agreement. Das ist dieses Blah, was man immer mit ja, ich, das ist okay, beim Installieren anklicken muss.
Diese fünf Seiten, die man runterscrollt und dann auf OK klickt, ohne zu viel zu lesen.
Also da stehen die herrlichsten Sachen drin. Ich kann jedem nur empfehlen da mal reinzugucken. Ein anderes schönes Beispiel war der Media Player von Microsoft. Wenn man sich da das neueste Update installiert, dann sagt er, sie gestatten Microsoft, dass ihr Computer plötzlich aufhören kann zu funktionieren. Und wir dürfen auch Software löschen, die uns nicht gefällt. Das zählt ernsthaft in dieser Eula drin. Und alle Leute klicken, okay, das ist ein paar Monate später rausgekommen. Und dann also, aha, ja wohl zu spät. Und der Lacher war, dass Microsoft das benutzt hat, um in den P2P-Netzten Filme in dem neuen Format zu verbreiten. Und wenn man die gesaugt hat und dann drauf gekriegt hat, dann hat der Media Player dieses Update automatisch gezogen, weil er gemerkt hat, das ist ein Codec, den hab ich noch nicht. Und damit musste man automatisch diese Eula anerkennen, um den Film gucken zu können. Also das ist schon alles sehr subtil. In Deutschland ist das gerichtlich nicht durchsetzbar. Und deshalb sucht Microsoft eben auch nach Methoden, diese Klauseln doch irgendwie technisch reinzudrücken. Und die Methode dafür scheint eben gerade TCPA zu sein im Moment.
Nun gibt es natürlich, wie so oft im Leben, die bösen Firmen, die großen, die Konzerne, die Trusts.
Und dann gibt es auf der anderen Seite die glücklichen Zufälle.
In diesem Fall heißt der glückliche Zufall Lucky Green.
Genau, Lucky Green ist jemand, der schon eine ganze Weile unterwegs ist in den Themen Cyberspace und Freiheit und Freiheit der Information und diese ganzen Dinge. Und der hat sich TCPA ein bisschen genauer angeguckt und hat sich auch die Patentseite ein bisschen genauer angeschaut. Mit dem wollen wir jetzt mal zu diesem Thema telefonieren. Yeah, I'm here. Lucky, we had an introduction into TCPA and we're now at the what can we do against it point. And there we came to the patent issue and probably could say something to what you have done and what you're planning to do to that.
As Microsoft is fond of stating, Microsoft's aspect of the TCPA, Microsoft's palladium initiative, was initially geared to prevent copying of digital media content, videos, DVDs, MP3s and so forth, primarily streamed content. However, Microsoft quickly realized that there would be substantial benefits to Microsoft in extending the digital rights management that palladium will enable to other parts of Microsoft products, in particular their Office suite of applications. Microsoft, for example, has announced the plan on wrapping the Word document and other Microsoft file formats in DRM, thus preventing clones and third-party applications from opening, reading or otherwise processing Microsoft documents. I hosted a panel on palladium and the TCPA at a recent YouthMix Security Conference, which included members from Microsoft as well as from the EFF, the Electronic Frontier Foundation, an online civil liberties group here in the US. On the panel, Microsoft's representative Peter Biddle stated that Microsoft did not at all intend to use palladium or TCPA to assist in the enforcement of software licensing.
Ich hab mal kurz mitgeschrieben, weil das ja doch vielleicht in einem oder anderen Augen aufgefallen ist, Lucky ist Amerikaner und ruft auch aus Amerika an, wenn ich das mal so... Es geht um Folgendes. Also Lucky, wir kommen noch nicht zu dem Punkt, der so interessant ist an Lucky, weil da arbeiten wir uns quasi hin, aber es ist erst mal so, er hat im Grunde noch mal zusammengefasst, was TCPA eigentlich macht, nämlich grundsätzlich zu verhindern, dass man bestimmte Kopiervorgänge macht, also so was wie Raubkopien von CDs, DVDs, ähnliches und so weiter. Und vor allen Dingen auch, und das ist Microsoft offensichtlich ziemlich wichtig, streamed Content, das heißt, was man sich so alles aus dem Internet so runterlädt, wie zum Beispiel mit dem Real Player, kennt ihr das vielleicht, wo man dann einfach, kann man mit Fritz übrigens auch machen, auf fritz.de kann man sich Fritz Radio gestreamt im Computer anhören, das ist dann im Grunde live, also ein bisschen versetzt. Aber wo es eben auch hingehen soll, und das mit Microsoft offensichtlich nicht so ganz zu ist, dass es sich dann auch auf Softwarestücke weiter ausdehnt, dieses ganze Verfahren, wie zum Beispiel Microsofts Office Suite, also dieses Programm, wo Excel drin ist und Word und so weiter. Und dass die Programmbestandteile, nämlich eben halt die Dokumente, die damit erstellt werden, leider nicht auf Third-Party-Applications, also auf Software anderer Hersteller, benutzt werden kann. Das heißt, ich kann dann leider nicht irgendwie mal ein kleines Star-Office aufmachen, das ich mir für umsonst geholt habe, für billiges Geld. Damit kriege ich nämlich das Word-Dokument dann leider nicht mehr auf. Und so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe, Panel heißt glaube ich sowas wie Gruppe oder Zusammenkunft von ein paar Leuten?
Naja, nee, das ist so ein Teil von einer Konferenz. Also da gibt es halt Themenbereiche eben. Und ein Panel war eben über Palladium und TCPA. Und da lag ich mit dem Vorsitzenden und da war eben auch jemand von Microsoft da und der sagte, nein, also das letzte woran sie denken würden, wäre das auf Software anzuwenden. Und ihnen geht es ja nur um den digitalen Content.
Genau, und die nächste Stelle sind wir jetzt.
Peter Biddle hat gesagt, dass nicht nur Microsoft nicht die Einrichtung von Palladium und TCPA zu einer gewissen Softwarelisanz zu nutzen, aber Microsoft und insbesondere die Palladium-Gruppe hatten absolut keine Ahnung, wie Palladium sogar zu einer Softwarelisanz gebraucht werden kann. Im Endeffekt hatte die Palladium-Team Microsofts Anti-Piracy-Gruppe mehrere Mal, als die Anti-Piracy-Gruppe sich die Palladium-Gruppe.
Ich bin ganz frech und darum haben wir auch gelacht, dass Microsoft nicht nur gesagt hat, nein, das haben wir nicht vor, sondern Microsoft hat auch gesagt, dass das was wir gerade erklärt haben, wie zum Beispiel Microsoft Office, dieses Software Licensing, nicht nur nicht, also nicht, wie sagt man, nicht, die hatten es nicht vor, sondern sie haben es nicht mal gecheckt, dass das überhaupt geht.
Huch, das ist möglich, da erschrecken wir uns ja selbst.
Und dann kam die Anti-Piracy-Liga da auf die zu und hat ihnen dann nochmal den Finger da so in die Wunde gelegt und dann haben die gesagt, komisch, die Wunde haben wir noch überhaupt nicht gesehen. Wenn das denn tatsächlich so sei und da scheint Lucky Green dann doch mal den Stier bei den Hörnern gepackt zu haben und Microsoft überhaupt keine Ahnung hat, was da geht, dann könnte man möglicherweise sich selber etwas lizenzieren, woran Microsoft ja noch gar nicht gedacht hat. Und dazu kommen wir jetzt.
Na man sollte vielleicht ein Detail des US-Patentsystems noch nennen. Es ist nämlich so, dass man Patente nur über Sachen genehmigt kriegen kann, die vorher noch niemand gemacht hat und wo vorher die Experten auch noch nicht angesprochen haben, dass es möglich wäre. Das heißt, wenn Microsoft selber sagt, es ist nicht möglich, dann ist es möglich, da überhaupt einen Partnern drauf anzumelden.
Ja, dann, to be more precise, the requirements to patent a, for the issue of a software patent here in the US are threefold. First, the idea has to be novel. Well, the idea clearly was novel because I've never heard of it, Microsoft claims to have never thought of it and Microsoft has worked on this project for five years. It has to be non-obvious.
Ja, das ist lustig. Ich glaube, ich denke mal als kleines Urteil darüber, Microsoft hat wahrscheinlich gedacht, stellen wir uns erst mal dumm, vielleicht merkt es ja keiner und jetzt hat Microsoft garantiert gesagt, verdammt, warum haben wir uns nur dumm gestellt? Denn es läuft wie folgt, fünf Jahre lang hat Microsoft an diesem Ding gearbeitet und das ist im Grunde das, was Felix gerade eben schon mal vorweggenommen hat über das Rechtssystem, das Patentsystem in den USA. Die haben fünf Jahre daran gearbeitet und mein Gott, wenn die in fünf Jahren nicht rausgekriegt haben, dass man da Software Licensing mit machen kann, eben halt diesen Part, dass man sowas mit Office machen könnte, dass eben halt diese kleinen Dokumente da auch so versehen werden können, dass sie bei anderen Sachen nicht geöffnet werden können. Ja gut, dann hat offensichtlich das Rechtssystem so weit eine Lücke, dass man eben beim Patentamt genau das anmelden kann, denn offensichtlich hat Microsoft nicht daran gedacht. Ja und ich denke mal genau das hat Lucky getan, oder Lucky? Nachdem Microsoft sich ungefähr fünf Jahre Zeit gelassen hat, den Fuchs nicht aus dem Bau zu lassen, ist dann Lucky am nächsten Tag einfach schon mal zum Patentamt gegangen und hat sich mit einer ähnlichen Software, wenn ich das verstanden hab, bzw. mit einer ähnlichen...
Nein, er hat schnell einen Patent erlassen in einem Kurzschluss und hat versucht, da alles zu erwähnen, was auch nur entfernt irgendwie benutzt werden könnte, um Software-Licenzen mit Palladium oder TCPA oder ähnlichen Systemen technisch zu erzwingen.
Weil, klar, Microsofts originales BRM-OS-Patent, auf dem Palladium und TCPA meistens gebeten sind, die Protektion digitaler Content, wie Streaming Media und wahrscheinlich Word-Dokumente, nicht verwendet wird. Aber wenn es um Software-Licenzen geht, dann ist das ein großer Konzern. Nicht weil ich unbekannte Software kopieren kann, sondern weil Microsoft in der Position ist, die Software für die Windows-Plattform zu schreiben, und die Software für die Windows-Plattform zu schicken. Wenn Microsoft die einzige Komponente der Software ist, wird Microsoft, wie sie es.
Ja, also im Grunde ist es so, dass man natürlich sagen kann, das ist die Gefahr, über die wir in der ersten halben Stunde schon gesprochen haben. Welche Macht im Grunde Microsoft in die Hände gelegt wird, wenn die tatsächlich dieses Patent hätten, was jetzt Lucky Green glücklicherweise erst mal beantragt hat. Was bedeuten würde, wenn Microsoft im Grunde sagen kann, wer jetzt noch Software entwickeln darf für Windows und wer nicht, das wäre Wahnsinn und sowas wie Share oder Freeware würde es dann nicht mehr lange geben. Aber meine Frage ist natürlich, ob Lucky Green glaubt, dass er im Endeffekt damit durchkommen wird. Jetzt mal abgesehen von diesem glücklichen Gefühl, was wir jetzt alle haben. Lucky, do you think that you're going to come through with this at last?
If that is indeed the case, I see no reason why the patent should not be issued. Now, granted, the US Patent Office can act somewhat strangely sometimes. Just because a patent should be valid doesn't necessarily mean it will be issued, but most likely it would be issued. In which case Microsoft could not use this technology without first obtaining a patent license from me. And I of course would only license this patent for socially responsible purposes. On the other hand, Microsoft may upon searching the files further determine that, oh, they've actually thought of this long before I did. Well, if so, then Microsoft will need to provide documentation of this fact to the Patent Office to prevent the Patent Office from either issuing the patent or more likely, this is how these things are done in patent law, or more likely challenge my patent as it has been issued claiming prior art. If so, there will be an extensive discovery period during which myself and my attorneys will get to examine Microsoft's internal documents on Palladium and PCPA, which undoubtedly will include the intended uses of the technology. So no matter what the outcome is, I believe the consumer wins.
Ja, es gibt im Grunde zwei Szenarios.
Das erste wäre, also was passieren würde, wenn Microsoft sich jetzt natürlich dagegen wehrt, was relativ wahrscheinlich ist. Erstes Szenario wäre, Microsoft hat wirklich nicht daran gedacht, diese Software Licensing da möglich zu betreiben mit TCPA Palladium. Das ist relativ unwahrscheinlich, weil das ist ja eigentlich der fette Kuchen an der Sache, aber kann ja sein, dass Microsoft wirklich so verrückt ist und so doof, dass es in fünf Jahren nicht darauf gekommen ist. Gut, dann gibt es Szenario Nummer zwei. Microsoft findet aus Versehen heraus, dass sie da doch schon vor fünf Jahren dran gedacht haben, dass es vielleicht für Software Licensing gut wäre, was bewirken würde, dass die Patentanmeldung, die Lucky Green gemacht hat, nutzlos ist, weil sie eben mal später gekommen ist. Allerdings würde das bedeuten, sie müssten die Dokumente vorlegen, in denen das steht, und das müssen eindeutige Dokumente sein, Entwicklungsdokumente und ähnliches. Und darauf freut sich Lucky Green dann wiederum auch, weil dann könnte er mit seinen Anwälten zusammen ja mal diese ganzen Entwicklungspapers von Microsoft durchforsten, dann könnte man diesem Konzern sozusagen in die Karten gucken. Und das ist auch ein ungleicher Spaß wahrscheinlich.
Lucky, eine Frage von mir. Also muss man nicht prüfen, dass du die Information veröffentlicht hast, wie man das vor der Patenten-Applikation macht?
Nicht hier in den USA.
Die Nachfrage war jetzt noch, ob es nicht veröffentlicht sein muss. Ist es in Deutschland so? Also in Deutschland muss es offensichtlich veröffentlicht sein, damit klar ist, der oder die haben das erfunden. In Amerika ist es nicht so, da muss nur klar sein, er hat es vorher erfunden. Das muss dann stichhaltig bewiesen sein, wahrscheinlich.
Wenn Microsoft mir 1 Billion Dollar für eine non-exklusiv Patent-License zahlen würde, würde ich die Billion Dollar für eine Kursverwendung nutzen, die den Kompetenzverhältnis im Software-Markt behält.
Microsoft hat jetzt ziemlich viel Geld. Einfach sagen würde, du, wir kaufen dich und was Lucky Green dann machen würde. Und gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit, es nicht zu nehmen. Oder eben zu sagen, ich nehme diesen Haufen Code. Zum Beispiel nehmen wir mal so eine Summe wie eine Billion Dollar. Und die bzw. eine Billion ist eine Milliarde Mark, also bzw. Euro. Nehmen wir einfach mal Euro. Und damit würde Lucky Green in dem Fall aber Folgendes machen, einfach zu versuchen, diese Summe aufzuwenden, um zu versuchen, den Softwaremarkt gerecht zu halten und eben anderen zu erlauben, da auch noch einzusteigen und mit diesem Geld im Grunde, wie nennt man das, den Markt aufrechtzuerhalten sozusagen. Und im Grunde Microsofts eigenes Geld zu benutzen, um Microsoft entgegenzuarbeiten, was natürlich auch eine schöne Vorstellung ist.
Kannst du etwas auf der legislativen Seite des Problems sagen? Dass es diesen einen Senator Hollings ist, der die TCPA durch ein Gesetz versucht hat?
Ja, absolut. Die TCPA und TCPA sind die technischen Gründe, um die digitale Kontrolle zu erheben. Es gibt einen anderen Teil der Kontrolle, dass mit TCPA und TCPA in der Lage neue und sehr gefährliche Gründe für Kontrollen in der Lage. Hollings kam, um eine Technologie, die sehr ähnlich wie PCP und Palladium in allen zukünftigen PCs zu mandieren. Jetzt natürlich mit den letzten Wahlkommissionen und dem Fall, dass ein Bill tot ist, aber es ist der Meinung, dass nicht nur das, aber auch mehrere ähnliche Bills wieder in der Sendung im Senat vorbeiführen werden.
Sobald ich das verstanden hab jetzt, wenn ich da jetzt noch ordentlich so drin stecke, ist es ja so, dass dieser den Namen Fritz hatten wir ja schonmal, das ist ja nicht nur unser Sendername, sondern auch der Name desjenigen, des Senators, der das Ganze vorantreibt in den USA. Senator Fritz Hollings heißt der. Und die eine Seite ist halt bei TCPA und Palladium, dass man inhaltliche Kontrolle betreiben kann, dass man sagen kann, okay, wer kann Dokumente überhaupt lesen, dass alle von Apple die Microsoft Dokumente nicht mehr lesen könnten. Das wäre natürlich krass, weil die hassen sich ja. Oder dass eben halt bestimmte Dokumente nur einmal geöffnet werden können und ähnliches. Das ist natürlich sehr interessant für so Content. Man leitet sich jetzt die DVD nicht mehr im DVD Laden aus, sondern holt sich die online, die kann aber nur einmal angeschaut werden und das nur 24 Stunden lang und so weiter und so fort. Und die andere Seite ist aber, dass in diesem Senat jetzt vorangetrieben wird, das unabhängig von Microsoft zu machen, also dass nicht nur Microsoft das vorantreibt, sondern eben halt auch der amerikanische Senat in diesem Fall. Was bedeutet, dass man erwartet, dass der Großteil aller Hardware irgendwann mit TCPA und Palladium ausgestattet sein wird, und sofern es mehrere Bills geben wird?
Ist es das, was ich richtig verstanden habe?
Was ich versuche, ist es halt tatsächlich verpflichtend zu machen. Das heißt zu sagen, ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt müssen TCPA und Palladium ähnliche Strukturen in allen neuen PCs...
Also rechtlich gesehen?
Rechtlich gesehen. Also es geht darum, die Sätze da durchzudrücken.
Man sollte vielleicht sagen, müssen, das ist tatsächlich mit Haftstrafe verbunden, wenn man es nicht tut. Also die Idee ist, wenn man zum ersten Mal einen Rechner verkauft, ab dem Datum, ich glaube 2004, Wagngespräch, dann kann man bis zu fünf Jahre in den Knast kommen oder eine halbe Million Dollar Strafe aufgedrückt kriegen und das verdoppelt sich, wenn man es noch mal macht. Also das sind tatsächlich heftige Strafen, die da ausgesetzt sind. Und im Grunde völlig klar, das kann sich da niemand leisten, das nicht zu tun.
Mal so eine Zwischenfrage, was mir immer auffällt ist, ich hole mir immer die Rele, versuche ja, wenn ich irgendwie Browser oder so, mir einen sicheren Browser runterzuladen, da gibt es dann solche Einschränkungen. Ich weiß, du lachst gut, aber es gibt ja immer solche Einschränkungen, da steht dann sowas wie, dass der 128 so und so Bit-Verschlüsselungscode nur in den USA benutzt werden darf, aber nicht in Europa.
Ja, das ist glücklicherweise eine Altlast der Geschichte heute. Das ist nicht mehr so.
Das ist mittlerweile erledigt. So Lucky, what do you think is the timeline on all this? Will there be significant progress in the next month or will it be stuck in the Senate and the House?
Oh, the bill is dead for the session and Senator Hollings, in fact, has lost his committee chair in the recent election. But Senator Hollings, so the Hollings bill itself is dead. There has been one in the House, a companion bill, the Hollings bill in the House. Hollings, of course, is in the Senate. Similar bills are expected to be introduced in the new session once Congress reconvenes. I would not expect much initiatives to take place in either the House or the Senate on these issues until sometime mid-next year. However, there is no rush to get this bill passed because the technology will not be a ready best-case scenario in 2004 or more likely in 2005.
Also was Lucky sagt, ist, dass die momentan diese Senator Hollings seinen Kommitivvorsitz verloren hat, indem er versucht hat, im Senat dieses Gesetz durchzubringen, was die Sache ein bisschen verzögert, was aber nicht dazu führen wird, dass es nicht stattfinden wird, weil...
Na, das Gesetz selber ist gescheitert.
Genau, aber es gibt halt andere Ansätze, andere Vorschläge, die halt von anderen Leuten da vorgebracht werden und wo man halt sicher sein kann, dass so im nächsten halben Jahr erstmal nicht viel passiert, weil die Technologie noch nicht so weit ist, aber spätestens dann werden sie es wohl halt nochmal versuchen.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum ich das ganze Zeit falsch verstanden hab. Ich bin so geeicht auf Bill Gates, dass ich immer Bills verstanden hab und dachte, ach der meint jetzt ganz viele verschiedene Bills, aber Bill heißt ja so wie Bill of Rights, auch Gesetz einfach.
So Lucky, do you think that the current wave of that more and more hardware manufacturers sign on to TCPA that it will continue or do you think that there might be someone recognizing, saying okay, there might be a market niche for me producing non-TCPA hardware maybe in Taiwan?
In the PC space, I believe it is extremely unlikely that non-TCPA, non-Palladium hardware will survive for the same reason that AMD signed on to the initiative. Initially, when Microsoft approached Intel, telling Intel, listen folks, we need particular features for the CPU, we need a new Ring-1 functionality in the CPU. Intel was very happy because they thought along these lines before with processor ID and encrypted instruction sets and so forth. In Microsoft, after Intel agreed and went to AMD and said, told AMD, listen folks, you have two choices. You can either provide these features in your CPU or Windows 2005 will not run on AMD chips. Which of the two is it going to be? Well, I think AMD's answer was pretty much a given. And that's in fact the answer that they gave. I don't believe that there is a hardware manufacturer, be that in the US or in Taiwan, that can economically produce current generation CPUs without the Windows market. Without being the CPUs being used for the Windows market.
I talked to some people and they told me, okay, this RIPmix burn slogan was not for nothing.
And I wholeheartedly agree. Certainly Apple at this point in time is sitting on the sidelines. There are some vendors that are sitting on the sidelines. Apple at this point in time doesn't need to get involved. Apple is perfectly happy to let Microsoft take the heat. If Microsoft in the end wins, if Palladium actually comes to bear and the PC platform becomes the Palladium world, then depending on what laws may be passed by Congress, Apple may or may not come around. It's purely to guess. Meanwhile Apple has all the reason in the world to do nothing at the moment and watch while Microsoft, Intel and AMD receive that PR.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz die letzten beiden Fragen. Da geht es natürlich darum, zum einen was wird passieren mit anderen Hardware Herstellern? Könnte es nicht sein, das war die Frage von Frank, das meinetwegen ein taiwanesischer Hardware Hersteller, der sagt, gut, dann machen wir halt da nicht mit und machen halt was dagegen. Und da hat Lucky dann kurz erzählt, wie das wahrscheinlich gelaufen sein wird, was relativ wahrscheinlich ist. Microsoft ist zu Intel gegangen, Intel und Microsoft haben das Ding jetzt zusammen hochgezogen und Intel hat bei den Features, die Microsoft ganz gerne haben wollte, zur Überwachung und ähnlichen Sachen und Sachen Sicherheit, sich relativ wohl gefühlt, weil genau die Features, da arbeiten sie in anderer Art und Weise zumindest sowieso schon lange dran und nachdem das mit Intel und Microsoft klar war, ist dann Microsoft zu AMD gegangen, hat gesagt, pass mal auf, Jungs, ihr habt zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder ihr macht da mit und baut diese Features auch in eure Chips oder eure AMD Prozessoren werden eben halt nicht mehr lauffähig sein mit Windows 2005. Dann wird das eben halt nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten und da hat AMD dann gesagt, gut, dann setzt uns auch mal auf die Liste, so wird es wahrscheinlich gelaufen sein. Und dann war eben halt die Nacht...
Let me just add this very briefly. I was told by a member of the Microsoft Palladium team in front of two witnesses that AMD had no choice.
Ah, es gibt sogar Zeugen, also AMD hatte keine Chance. Gut, das ist noch beunruhigender. Jedenfalls gibt es dann noch die Frage, was ist mit Apple, weil Apple eben halt nicht auf dieser TCPA Support-Liste drauf ist. Motorola, die die Prozessoren für die Apple-Sachen produzieren, allerdings ist auf dieser Liste drauf und es ist wohl so, dass die Apple momentan einfach abwartet, was nun passiert, weil die gucken erstmal, was Microsoft macht. Wenn Microsoft das Ding durchkriegt und das vielleicht sogar gesetzlich eben durch den Senat irgendwann festgelegt werden kann oder werden muss, dann wird sich Apple da wahrscheinlich auch hinbequem. Momentan warten die einfach ab und können dann haben dann alle Optionen offen, wenn man so möchte. Ob das besser ist, ist eine andere Frage.
Eine Frage, die wir in der aktuellen Dokumentation von TCPA und Palladium ein bisschen ambitiell fühlen, ist, was über Content Creators ist. Es scheint wie eine Schleimdase, um Content in einem TCPA Palladium System zu kreieren, weil man oft von einer Maschine zum anderen, zum nächsten und so weiter und so fort.
Wenn man heute an High-End Content Creation Systems schaut, dann sieht man, dass es heute ein High-End Content Creation System gibt, das mit Contenten zu tun kann, die Consumer-Grade-Systems nicht tun können, und in der USA sind die nicht ermittelt. Diese Differenz zwischen High-End Content Creation Systems und Content Creation Systems für die restlichen von uns wird sicherlich weitergehen, und das ist nicht etwas, was die Content Aggregatoren unglücklich übernehmen, da es die Konkurrenz von Contenten limitiert. Was du findest, ist, dass es Verkaufsverkaufsverkaufssoftware gibt, die die Verkaufsverkaufsverkaufsverkaufssoftware erlauben, aber diese Versionen werden auf eine bestimmte CPU oder eine bestimmte Mutterboard verbaut. Und wenn diese Versionen auch aus den Offices des Movie Studios oder aus den Offices von Microsoft leugnen würden, könnte man nichts mit der Software tun, weil es nicht auf der Mutterboard gehen würde.
Willst du das übersetzen oder willst du das ein bisschen technisch? Also die Frage ist natürlich, wie wird es dann für die Entwickler sein? Das haben wir ja in der ersten Stunde hier im Chaosradio vorhin schon mal versucht klarzumachen. Wenn ich irgendwie Software schreibe, dann mache ich die ja nicht ganz fertig und dann läuft die hundertprozentig und dann kann ich sie mir irgendwie von Microsoft auf welche Art und Weise auch immer lizenzieren, registrieren oder ähnliches machen lassen, damit das dann auch mit dem ganzen Zeug zusammenläuft. Sondern ich muss immer mal probieren, wie läuft das, was ich bis jetzt habe, so weit. Und man könnte keine Software entwickeln, wenn man sich jedes Häppchen von Microsoft eben abnicken lassen müsste. Deswegen wird es irgendwie, dass man zumindest, Lucky Green, sowas wie Entwickler Hardware geben, auf der das läuft. Und das wird in der Regel wahrscheinlich dann abhängig sein von einer CPU, also von Prozessor oder wahrscheinlich ja noch von den Motherboards, also den ganzen großen Steckplatten, die unten im Computer drin sind. Und wenn dann sowas entwickelt wird, dann läuft das eben halt auch nur auf diesen Entwickler-Maschinen und eben halt nicht auf den End-User-Systemen. Da würde das dann im Endeffekt gar nicht drauf funktionieren.
Ja, also es ging noch ein bisschen weiter. Es ging primär auch um Content Creation, also Leute, die Filme machen und Musik machen und so weiter und so fort. Und das Lucky halt meint ist, dass es dann halt spezielle Systeme für diese Leute geben wird, die halt dem End-User nicht zur Verfügung stehen. So Lucky, do we think that in the end this will take the wind out of the digital video boom, because everybody's buying cheap DVD-Cameras and cutting the stuff on a cheap PC and this will end then?
I don't believe so. The content aggregators and content distributors will be perfectly happy for you to distribute content that cannot be copy protected, while their own content is copy protected. They don't care whether movies that you may produce, from which they make no money, get pirated and thus leave you without revenue.
Okay, was Haki sagt, ist, dass er meint, dass die großen Contentfirmen, also die Filmstudios und so weiter, damit kein Problem haben werden, wenn die Leute weiter digitale Videos machen und ihre eigenen Videos produzieren, ohne Kopierschutz, solange die Videos von den großen Studios halt weiter kopierschutz sind.
Gibt's bei Napster halt nur noch Urlaub von Klaus? Aber ich sag Napster, ich glaub, das werd ich dann auch noch in kinderweiten Farben machen. Papa, was ist eigentlich Napster? Ach, das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Ja, das war ja sehr aufschlussreich.
Wo können wir uns ja im Grunde bedanken? Ich meine, wie viel Uhr ist es in Amerika eigentlich? Toll, wir haben in Amerika telefoniert. Wahnsinn, das ist ein Push-Wert. So, meine Damen und Herren, ihr hört das Chaosradio auf Fritz im Studio Frank, Felix und meine Person Max. Chaosradio Menschen eben halt Felix und Frank. Thema des heutigen Abends. Ach, da war es was, was so ein bisschen traurig stimmt. Es geht um TCPA. Könnte man das eigentlich mit dem mit dem bezeichnen als proprietäre Software? Sowas ist das sowas bzw. proprietäre Hardware oder Software?
Nee, proprietär heißt also, das ist ein Effekt von TCPA, diese Linie ein bisschen zu verwischen. Also proprietär heißt eigentlich Software und Hardware, von dem ich keinem sage, wie sie funktioniert. Und das Gegenteil davon ist offene Hardware. Nun ist es so, dass die TCPA-Systeme durchaus dokumentiert sind. Also da gibt es Dokumente rüber und die sind wohl auch so halbwegs offen, wie das funktioniert. Das heißt, man kann es schon nachbauen, die TCPA-Systeme, aber das macht sie, also das ist nicht proprietär, sondern es ist halt eine andere Kategorie jetzt.
Also geschlossen wäre der richtige Eindruck.
Genau, geschlossen ist schon richtig, aber sie sind halt schon dokumentiert.
Das heißt, ich halte nicht mal geheim, dass ich den Leuten wirklich meinen Bären aufbinde, sondern ich sage es ihnen auch noch, dass ich das tue. Das ist ja noch fieser.
Ja, es ist auch ganz lustig zu sehen, wenn man mal auf die Website von TCPA geht, das ist trustedcomputing.com oder was dort auch. Ich weiß nicht, aber jedenfalls, da ist nicht mal eine Liste von den Leuten.
Dort auch wäre er ja nun wirklich infam.
Na ja, also wieso?
Das machen viele, dass sie Konsortien gründen für ihre Trusts und Kartellzwecke und dann auch wieso? Wir sind hier Non-Commercial-Blubber. Also das ist schon durchaus üblich, da Punkt Org zu machen, aber ich also wenn wenn unsere Hörer jetzt gerade zu Hause sind...
trustedcomputing.org Punkt Org, naja, das ist schon echt die harte.
Also wer zu Hause gar ein Internet hat, kann ja mal auf der Site versuchen, eine Liste von den Members zu kriegen. So nur um mal zu sehen, ob die Leute den Eindruck haben, dass es ehrenwert ist, bei der TCPA Mitglied zu sein und wo man gerne mit hausieren geht, weil bei üblichen Plattformen, wie zum Beispiel Team DDR oder so, ist auch so eine Industrieplattform. Da steht natürlich verständlich die Anzahl der Members und wer das alles ist, weil die Leute das für die Werbung benutzen. Aber bei TCPA kann man ja mal gucken gehen, ob jeder auf Anhieb die...
Die Member Companies sind passwortgeschützt.
Das ist echt der Hammer. Die Firmen sind sich voll im Klaren darüber, dass das echt unpopulär ist, was die da tun, wenn das rauskommt.
Die warten halt, bis es dann entweder keiner mehr werden kann und dann auch, wir sind schon immer dabei gewesen.
Es gibt eine FAQ zu dem Thema von Ross Anderson, das ist einer der führenden Sicherheitsexperten aus Großbritannien. Und der hat das schön ausgedruckt, der meinte, Intel ist erst verbrannt worden mit ihrer Seriennummer im Prozessor und jetzt kommen sie zurück, um die Macht der vielen Zahlen zu benutzen. Die kommen einfach an Masse zurück. Was Anderson sagt, Intel hat sich zurückgezogen, die Wunden geleckt und kommt jetzt mit allen Freunden zurück und hat jetzt eine Rotte von Leuten und da kann ich nicht jetzt natürlich hinschauen und sagen, ja dann kaufe ich halt meinen Rechner in Flower Power Enterprises aus Taiwan. Aber letztlich ist es so, ich hab nicht wirklich eine Wahl. Also eine schöne Analogie dazu ist, die TCPA sagt gerne, das ist eine Opt-in-Technologie. Also ich kann mir aussuchen, ob ich das anschalte oder nicht. Aber man muss sich vor Augen halten, tanken beim Auto ist auch eine Opt-in-Sache. Ja, ich kann auch sagen, ich tank jetzt nicht mehr, aber dann kann ich halt nicht Auto fahren. Also das ist schon vergleichbar.
Also was denkt ihr darüber? Denn wir haben jetzt mit Lucky Green die ganze Zeit telefoniert. Was denkt ihr darüber? Wird sich das durchsetzen oder nicht? Wollt ihr das haben oder nicht? Ist das wichtig oder ist es nicht wichtig? Ist es vielleicht wichtig, um das Internet sicherer zu machen und Ähnliches? 0331 70 97 110, unsere Telefonnummer. Und es gibt auch eine E-Mail-Adresse, über die ihr euch beteiligen könnt. Den Zettler, den ihr natürlich verschlört. Nee, hier ist er. Und zwar 78, weil es die 78. Sendung ist, als Zahl geschrieben, also 7 und 8, at chaosradio.ccc.de für Fragen und Hinweise zu genau dieser Sendung. Grundsätzlich könnt ihr natürlich auch eure Meinung abgeben bei chaosradio.ccc.de. Und die Webseite zur Sendung gibt es auch, und zwar http.de, und wir haben natürlich ein Interesse mit A2D, bei www.chaosradio.ccc.de und am Telefon ist hoffentlich noch der Frank, der sich Lucky dann über Telefon aus den USA über sein Telefon anhören musste. Frank, bist du noch da?
Ja, gleich bin ich noch da.
Hat ein bisschen länger gedauert, wir haben uns da verquatscht und da mussten wir noch übersetzen, aber es war ja sehr aufschlussreich. Würdest du das durchsetzen, was glaubst du?
Ich denke mal, dass die Gesellschaft, die Menschen draußen bei uns im Lande, also wenn es sich in den USA mit Gesetzen durchsetzen soll, ok, da kann man sich nicht großartig gegen wehren, aber wenn es allein der Markt entscheiden sollte, denke ich, man wird sich das nicht wirklich durchsetzen. Wir haben es gesehen bei HP, die haben versucht, mit Microsoft so eine Box rauszubringen, die jetzt irgendwie mit DVD-Brenner und so eine Geschichte eingebaut war. Und die mussten die ganzen Palladium-Fanskampfs wieder deaktivieren aus der Geschichte, weil das Ding Ladenhüter geworden ist. Und zu dem Stichwort würde ich auch noch ganz gerne sagen, dass es ja auch noch so Initiativen gibt zu Open-Hardware-Geschichten. Das kenne ich jetzt nicht weiter tiefer aus, aber ich denke mal, dass es für die Leute, die wirklich sagen, ok, ich muss mich von diesem Ganzen distanzieren, ich möchte mich nicht zu tun haben, immer noch eine Möglichkeit geben wird, auch an Hardware und an Software ranzukommen, denke ich mal, die eben dieses Spielchen nicht mitmacht.
Ja, prinzipiell ist das richtig. Also es gibt unter anderem das FCPU Projekt, das sich bemüht, eine freie CPU zu bauen, so mit komplett eigenem Befehlsatz und so. Und das ist auch ganz interessant, nur die sind weit davon entfernt, da irgendwas zu haben, was man kaufen kann. Und selbst wenn die mit ihrem Projekt fertig sind, was noch nicht der Fall ist, dann müsste man immer noch über die entsprechenden Fertigungstechniken verfügen. Und um das mal so ein bisschen in Perspektive zu rücken, die drei PC-Prozessoren, die es im Moment gibt, kommen von Intel, die kommen von AMD und die kommen von VIA. Das sind so die drei Hersteller im Grunde. Und alle drei sitzen in den USA. VIA ist eigentlich eine taginesische Firma, aber die Prozessoren kommen von Centaur Technologies, die sitzen in Texas. Das heißt, es wird auf absehbare Zeit, nämlich Phase 2 von TCPA, ist heute schon dokumentiert, da ist dieser gesamte Kram im Prozessor drin. Das heißt, ich kann überhaupt keinen PC mehr bauen, der nicht diesen TCPA an Bord hat. Also natürlich kann man den einfach nicht nutzen und da Linux drauf fahren, aber das hat trotzdem gewisse Einschränkungen. Was wir vielleicht mal gleich tun sollten, ist die Gelegenheit nutzen. Wer sich für freie Software und freie Hardware interessiert, der ist herzlich eingeladen, uns beim Chaos Communication Congress dieses Jahr wieder zu besuchen, wie jedes Jahr zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr.
27. bis 29.12. und zwar am Haus am Kölnischen Park in Berlin.
Genau, das ist auch auf unserer Webseite ein bisschen verlinkt.
Genau, www.ccc.de, da gibt es dann irgendwo einen Link zum Kongress und wo das Hoffnungsfall des Kongressprogramm online sein wird.
Es ist sogar noch ein Call for Papers offen, also wenn einer von euch jetzt sehr kurzfristig in der Lage ist, einen interessanten Beitrag vom Kongress zu leisten, ist auch noch herzlich eingeladen. Und da können wir dann auch über freie Hardware diskutieren.
Da darf dann gemeinsam geweint werden.
Na ja, so ein bisschen positiver Ausblick gibt es schon noch.
Hey, jetzt habe ich mal euren Pessimismus angenommen.
Den haben wir uns zum Ende aufgehoben. Ja, wenn alle Leute schon schlafen, dann kommt ja unser Optimismus drauf.
Aber Frank, jetzt mal im Ernst, ich meine klar, dieses eine Ding, wovon du gesprochen hast, mit HP und wo TCPA schon irgendwie implementiert war, das hätte sich als Ladenhüter erwiesen. Aber was ist denn, wenn es nur noch das gibt?
Da müsste man, ja, für mich stellt sich die Frage, wenn wir sagen, okay, es kann nur noch das geben. Wenn USA sich das mit den Gesetzen durchsetzt, also wenn da wirklich ein Gesetz geschrieben wird und das auch durchkommt, dann, okay, dann hat man da keine Chance mehr auszuweichen, inwieweit wird das in Europa durchsetzen, inwieweit haben die, es geht ja nur um die Firmen, es geht um Content, es geht um Hollywood, es geht um die Musikindustrie und inwieweit wird hier bei uns in Deutschland, in Europa wirklich der Einfluss so weit gehen, dass wir sagen, okay, wir setzen das auch gesetzlich fest, dass es das enthalten muss und das dann dementsprechend natürlich, glaube ich, das bei uns nicht gesetzlich festgelegt ist. Dass es einfach auch Möglichkeiten gibt, das Ganze zu umgehen bzw. das Ganze auszuhebeln, da man einfach hier nicht diese Strafen zu befürchten hat und dadurch vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen Konkurrenz oder eben Konkurrenzsysteme sich belieben könnten. Wir reden von drei bis vier, fünf Jahren.
Das Problem dabei ist zweigestellig. Zum einen ist die USA nun schlicht und ergreifend mal der größte Computermarkt der Welt. Noch, also vielleicht bis die Chinesen soweit sind. Und zum anderen ist halt das Problem, dass natürlich die Content-Industrie-Lobby auch in Europa versucht, versucht massiv Gesetze durchzudrücken, die halt in diese TCPA-Richtung gehen. Das heißt also, Kontrollen durchzusetzen und so weiter und so fort. Da ist es halt leider nicht mehr so, dass Deutschland noch ein souveräner Staat ist, sondern es ist halt so, dass diese Entscheidungen weitgehend auf EU-Ebene gefällt werden. Und wie wir alle wissen, sind gerade auf EU-Ebene nicht unbedingt unsere kompetentesten Politiker angesiedelt, sondern die, mit die man hier halt nicht mehr so richtig brauchen konnte. Und was halt in der Regel nicht dazu führt, dass da besonders sinnvolle und günstige Gesetze entstehen, die dann aber trotzdem halt in nationales Recht umgewandelt werden müssen. Also insofern bin ich da langfristig nicht besonders optimistisch, dass die rechtliche Lage in Deutschland, wenn wir uns nicht echt anstrengen und viel Glück haben, wesentlich sich von der in den USA unterscheiden wird.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Deswegen machen wir auch die Sendung hier. In der Hoffnung, dass ihr jetzt alle aufsteht und rebelliert. Also das Problem ist, in der EU sind tatsächlich schon Gespräche am Laufen, wie man diese Art von Gesetze auch in Europa machen muss. Und das ist dann sicher alles ein bisschen langfristiger. Dann haben die Einzelstaaten zwei Jahre Zeit oder was. Und dann muss das aber umgesetzt werden in lokales Recht. Und da muss im Grunde jetzt was getan werden, ansonsten ist das zu spät. Also wir haben ja leider schon mehrere Gesetze auf EU-Ebene gehabt, die wir viel zu spät mitgekriegt haben. Unter anderem ist gerade auch NAKA-Gesetzgebung gerade noch in der Besprechung. Aber letztendlich ist es so, wenn man bei den EU-Sachen als einzelner Bürger auch nicht so viel machen kann, dann ist doch jetzt der Zeitpunkt, wo noch am ehesten was drin ist. Da hilft es auch nicht, wenn so einzelne Leute sagen, das wird dir alles verfassungsfeindlich in Deutschland oder so. Oder Reverse-Engineering-Rechte, die sind auch gerade am bröckeln europaweit. Also das ist alles nicht so toll, die Ausblicke europaweit. Da muss man echt gucken, was wir da noch drehen können. Aber insgesamt war wir den Optimismus schon aufrechterhalten. Freut uns, dass du hier anrufen hast.
Ich meine, wir werden schon mal zu eurer Revolution und öffentlich-rechtlichen Radio aufrufen dürfen, nehmen wir die Gelegenheit natürlich da.
Es ist ja immer die Revolution auf einer anderen Ebene. Jeden Tag eine andere Revolution. Frank, dank dir. Was mich eigentlich wundert ist, ich warte ja dauernd auf diese argumentatorische Peitsche. Wenn dann mal alles so proprietär läuft, dann wird es ja auch wieder billiger. Das heißt, wenn die CDs mal billiger, weil die werden ja dann nicht mehr alle Raubkopiert, dann könnte man die endlich mal für 5 Euro bekommen. Und dann werden die Filme billiger.
Du meinst, dass du dieselbe Argumentation, wieso das Studiengebühren des Studiums besser wird?
Ich dachte, es heißt früher immer, CDs sind so teuer, weil so viele Raubkopien auf dem Markt sind. Und warum spricht denn keiner davon, dass das dann wieder billiger wird?
Ich meine, das Preis wird erleben, meine Damen und Herren.
Weil die CDs heute schon nicht kopiert werden. Das ist doch der Lacher. Die ganzen Statistiken, die von der CD-Industrie rausgegeben werden, die zählen nicht die Raubkopien, sondern die Rohlinge. Und ich brenne ungefähr pro Tag einen Rohling an Backups raus. Das heißt, allein das wird selbstverständlich alles als böse, böse Raubkopierer mitgezählt von der Industrie. Also es gibt überhaupt keine so vernünftigen Statistiken darüber, wie viel Musik tatsächlich kopiert wird. Und natürlich kann ich persönlich sagen, dass ich meine gesamten Musik-CDs noch einmal in MP3 oder auf irgendeiner anderen CD habe, damit ich die in den Urlaub mitnehmen kann. Ich hab zuhause 600 CDs, die werde ich nicht in den Urlaub mitnehmen. Wenn ich mal ein paar Wochen irgendwo hinfahre, dann würde ich meine MP3s natürlich dabei haben, weil das passt in eine kleine Tasche. Und das ist keine Raubkopie. Nach dem momentanen Gesetz, das wird sich mit der TCPA auch ändern.
Ist klar, da wird es schon eine Raubkopie, wenn man die CD mit ins andere Zimmer nimmt. Ihr könnt anrufen und euch zu dem Thema äußern unter 0373 77 97 1 1 0. Was denkt ihr, ist sowas sinnvoll oder eher nicht? Beziehungsweise wird es sich denn entwickeln oder wird es vielleicht einfach im Sande verlaufen?
Eine Frage, wir hatten nur noch eine Frage. Würdet ihr mehr für einen Computer oder ein Gerät ausgeben, wenn ihr damit Filme und Musik kopieren könntet? Also gesetzt den Fall, wir kommen jetzt in Richtung eine Gesellschaft, wo Kopierschutz überall ist. Würdet ihr dann für Geräte mehr ausgeben, wenn sie euch doch die Sachen kopieren lassen?
Der Jörg ist am Telefon.
Der Frank hat eben schon viel dazu gesagt. Ich habe eigentlich sehr viel Vertrauen zum Markt und dass der Markt sich alleine reguliert. Das heißt, die Nachfrage wird nicht da sein und dann wird es Verkauseinbrüche geben. Und dann wird sich auch ein Hersteller finden, der eben andere Hardware herstellt.
Naja, wir haben im Moment Rezession. Man sollte denken, jetzt würden die Hersteller besonders wenig tun, um die Kunden zu verstecken. Und gerade jetzt ist die Marktsituation, in der so ein Ding auf den Tisch kommt. Also wenn wir glauben würden, dass der Markt das reguliert, das wäre eher ein Argument, das im Moment verhindern würde, dass TCPA überhaupt diskutiert würde.
Naja, bloß, wenn ich jetzt einen Brenner mir vor eine Weile gekauft habe, habe ich darauf geachtet, dass er Subchannel lesen kann, um mit Lohn-CD zusammenzuarbeiten. Alle anderen wurden nicht mehr gekauft. Und dadurch haben sich die Hersteller darauf eingestellt. Und bringen eigentlich nur noch solche Hardware raus, die eben kompatibel ist dazu.
Also du würdest von dir selber sagen, du achtest beim Kauf darauf, Hardware zu kaufen, die dich nicht am Kopieren hindert oder die dich vielleicht sogar unterstützt.
Ja, na sicher. Und weil ihr vorhin mal gefragt habt, ob das denn sein muss. Ich bin eigentlich auch der Meinung, dass das Kopieren oder so nicht unbedingt für die breite Masse und für immer und für jeden da sein müsste. Also ich muss nicht in jeder Zeitschrift lesen, wie ich mein Handy freischalte, den Sinnendruck entferne oder so. Wer da Interesse hat, dann muss ich ein bisschen mit der Materie befassen. Und dann kommt der alleine an dem Wissen, was er braucht und was er kauft und wo er beim Kauf drauf achtet. Und wer sich dann halt bei Aldi einen Rechner kauft und dann steht TCPA dran und der kauft sich den und hat sich vorher überhaupt nicht informiert. Naja, mehr oder weniger Pech abseits, beim zweiten Mal ist er schlauer. Ich merke, das klappt nicht, informiert sich und achtet dann beim Hardwarekauf eben darauf. Und dann wird das nach einer Weile auch wieder andere Hersteller, die Prozessoren herstellen, die das TCPA nicht haben. Auch wenn die drei Firmen jetzt momentan noch nur in den USA sitzen, wo dann so ein Gesetz gibt.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Trugschluss. Das setzt ja einen Lernprozess voraus beim User. Der ist ja in der Regel überhaupt nicht vorhanden. Und ich glaube, 90% aller Menschen würden eher ihren Rechner bei Aldi kaufen, weil der im Zweifelsfall 200 Euro teurer ist. Oder billiger ist oder bei Lidl.
Die Leute setzen Windows ein, das ist eigentlich das Gegenargument. Wenn die Leute lernfähig wären wir das nicht so.
Na gut, die alternative Linie ist doch noch ein bisschen nicht für die breite Masse da, sag ich mal.
Was interessant ist, ist, wie solche Systeme dann vermarktet werden. Das erste Beispiel ist dieser Notebook von IBM, der schon TCPA Infrastruktur enthält und der wird schlicht als sichere Maschine vermarktet. Die hält in der Lage ist deine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln, deine E-Mail zu verschlüsseln und so weiter und so fort, dafür zu sorgen, dass niemand anders an den Rechner ran kann. Das wird natürlich das Marketing Argument sein. Sie werden die unglaublichsten Dinge behaupten, von wegen es würde möglicherweise gegen Spam oder gegen Viren helfen, was auch immer Marketer behaupten, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Das haben sie übrigens schon behauptet, das ist ganz lustig. Das war eine der ersten Behauptungen von Microsoft zu dem Thema. Das TCPA würde ja das Virenproblem beseitigen und Spam könnte man ja so auch beenden, weil man könnte ja dann einfach alle Mails rausfiltern von Leuten, die nicht TCPA-PCs haben. Und wenn man da ungefähr drei Sekunden drüber nachdenkt, fällt dann auf, dass sich der Spammer eben auch bei all den TCPA-PCs kauft und dann hat man eben doch wieder Spam.
Also die Frage war, glaubst du nicht, dass die Leute auf solche Argumente reinfallen?
Ja sicher zu Anfang, aber ich glaube schon, dass sie dann lernen oder sie können dann halt nicht kopieren. Das ist dann halt ihr Ding.
Was war denn deine erste Windows-Version, wenn ich mal fragen darf?
Das war 95.
Seitdem gab es 98 SE, es gab ME, es gab 2000 und du setzt die immer noch ein, oder?
Ich setze 98 ein.
Na ja, also um mal ganz phänisch jetzt hier zu sagen, hast du ja auch nicht gelernt eigentlich, dass Windows 95 deinen Sachen nicht entspricht und hast wieder bei denen gekauft. Und leider ist das so in deinem Leben.
Ich kann aber mit meinen Windows 98 das machen, was ich will.
Das denkst du doch auch nur, Jörg, im Hinblick darauf, dass vor den Toren die weitaus fiesere Version von Windows steht. Das heißt, du klopfst dir dann selber auf die Schulter und sagst, ja, meine ist auch scheiße, aber sie ist noch viel, viel besser. Und damit gehe ich dem Ganzen auf so einen Weg. Ich kenne auch noch irgendwelche Leute, die so, also ich weiß auch noch, Windows 3.11 lief blendend. Es war toll.
Was war denn das denn?
Das war zu meiner Zeit, als ich das erste Mal Doom gespielt habe.
Das war 3.11.
Uiuiui, kann mich nicht erinnern, dass Windows 3.11 jemals gut lief. Aber ist ja auch egal. Der Punkt ist einfach, die Leute lernen heute schon nicht daraus. Das kann man eben einfach sehen. Die Leute glauben Microsoft, dass die nächste Windows Version besser wird. Und die Argumentation, ja der Hundehaufen, in den ich reingetreten bin, war nicht so groß wie der, in den der andere da reingetreten ist. Das ist vielleicht kurzfristig ein bisschen beruhigend, aber langfristig ist das kein tragbares Konzept. Da muss man sich schon überlegen. Letztendlich man hört auch oft, ach ja, aber Linux, das geht ja alles noch nicht. Guckt es euch einfach mal an. Also ich weiß, dass es überall steht und das sieht auch schwierig aus vielleicht. Und wenn man da mit der Einstellung rangeht, dass es alles eh bestimmt alles ganz schwierig ist, ist es wahrscheinlich noch mal so schwierig wie vorher. Oder guckt euch von mir aus macOS an, guckt euch an, was da rumliegt. Aber lasst euch nicht auf Monopole ein. Microsoft ist nicht nur schlecht, weil die Software schlecht ist, sondern vor allem auch, weil es ein Monopol ist und weil man sie in ihren Praktiken unterstützt, wenn man eben weiter von ihnen Software kauft.
Ich hab noch was zu sagen. Ihr habt jetzt gesagt, man müsste die Hardware verändern, damit sie wieder läuft. Und das wär nicht für jeden unbedingt was. Nur wenn ich mein Auto verkaufen will, sag ich mal, und ich will den Tacho zurückdrehen lassen, kann es nicht selber, gibt es da genug, die das anbieten, die dann kommen und mir das machen. Genauso könnte man, wenn man jetzt, es nicht replizierbar ist, dieses Knacken, könnte man ja immer jemanden kommen lassen, der genau seinen Rechner halt für sich selber frei macht.
Das ist eine interessante Perspektive, da hab ich noch nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, das ist richtig, auf jeden Fall. Ich werde von dir kein Auto kaufen.
Man muss sich schon irgendwie überlegen, natürlich ist das kurzfristig beruhigend, aber wenn man da mal rückblickend drüber nachdenkt, dann hat man mit seinem Prozessorkauf einen Prozentsatz von der Kohle, ist benutzt worden, um diese Technologie zu entwickeln. Ein weiterer Prozentsatz ist dazu getan worden, um das in den Prozessor rein zu tun. Und der nächste Teil, den gebe ich noch zusätzlich obendrauf, um es wieder auszubauen. Da wird mein Geld für Sachen ausgegeben, die ich nicht unterstützen möchte. Selbst wenn es beruhigend sein mag, dass ich die Perspektive habe, eventuell das wieder rauszupopeln aus meiner Hardware, ist es doch so, dass ich durch den Kauf diese Technologien gefördert habe. Die Leute, die das entwickelt haben, die kriegen Geld dafür, dass sie das gemacht haben, um mich zu ärgern, obwohl ich es danach ausbaue.
Das ist der Preis, den ich dafür zahle, um kopieren zu können. Oder um nichts zu haben, da muss ich bereit sein, das auszugeben.
Online kriegen sie dich ja dann doch.
Das funktioniert irgendwann von ganz alleine, denke ich mal.
Wenn wir jetzt mal den Vergleich wählen, zum Beispiel mit der Xbox, wo man das relativ direkt vergleichen kann. Da gibt es halt auch Kopierschutzmechanismen, die mit Modchips ausgehebelt werden, ähnlich wie bei Autos. Da gibt es Dienstleister, wo man sein Ding hinschicken kann oder selber den Modchip anbauen kann.
Ich kann jetzt ziemlich angeschissen.
So etwas wird es halt für die PCs auch geben. Nur, dass solche Modchips natürlich auch online direktierbar sind. Das heißt, wenn ich dann online gehe mit dem System, kann Microsoft im Zweifel sagen, du hast da einen bösen Modchip drinne, du kriegst keinen Windows-Update mehr. Diese Dimension, dass das ganze Ding ja online ist und dass es sich permanent synchronisiert und permanent die Software-Blacklists aktualisiert, ist das Gemeine daran, dass man da schon ziemlich einen Aufwand treiben muss, um zu verhindern, dass man sich mit dem Modchip doch wieder ein Bus ins Knie schießt.
Na und selbst mit dem Geld, das man selbst bezahlt hat für den Prozessor, werden ja die Leute bezahlt, die die Maßnahmen ergreifen, um dann online die Modchips zu erkennen. Das ist ja auch mein Geld, was die bezahlt. Das finde ich schon als Gedanken sehr unbefriedigend, wenn ich die Leute bezahle, die mich ärgern. Gut, man kann jetzt sagen, die Straßenpolizisten, die mir Knöllchen reindrücken, bezahle ich auch mit meinem Geld. Ich kann aber auch nicht sagen, dass ich das erfreulich finde, wenn ich irgendwie Knöllchen kriege. Das ist schon eine Perspektive, über die man nachdenken muss. Wie schön man das findet und ob man da nicht doch irgendwas tun kann.
Tschüss, schönen Abend noch. Ach man, das sind ja tolle Aussichten. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich finde es ja selber auch anstrengend. Man wird immer sehr angestachelt durch diese Themen, die im Chaosradio hier in der Regel immer um das eine kreisen. Nämlich, es lohnt sich, seine Bürgerrechte in Anspruch zu nehmen. Aber seine Bürgerrechte dann wirklich in Anspruch zu nehmen, kostet unglaubliche Kraft.
Ja, das ist dann leider... Es gibt so einen schönen Spruch über Gelegenheiten. Gelegenheiten werden häufig nicht ergriffen, weil sie wie Arbeit aussehen. Und so ist das halt, wenn man was will. Oder um das mal aus einer anderen Perspektive, es gab so einen schönen Vortrag von Lawrence Lessing zum Thema IFF und die zivilen Rechte der Leute. Und da hat er gefragt, wie viele Leute geben von euch Spenden an Institutionen wie die IFF, die ist vorhin von Lucky schon erwähnt worden. Und dann gingen irgendwie vier Arme runter. Und dann meinte er, wie viele Spenden mehr als die der Telekom in den Rachen werfen für schlechten DSL-Service. So als Frage. Und das finde ich einen Gedanken, den fand ich sehr beeindruckend. Also wenn man das aus der Perspektive sieht, wie viel Geld man eigentlich ausgibt, um Monopole zu fördern, und wie wenig man im Vergleich ausgibt, um was dagegen zu tun, dass neue Monopole entstehen, dann kann man sich schon fragen, ob man nicht mehr Geld spenden sollte. Wenn man schon selber nicht die Zeit hat, nach Luxemburg zu fahren oder in die EU-Gesetzgebung einzugreifen, dann soll man schon gucken, dass man sein Geld auch in angemessener Höhe dafür zur Verfügung stellt.
Und Spenden tut gut wie nichts anderes, kann ich nur bestätigen. Ich hab das mal fürs rote Kreuz gemacht, das ist ein tolles Gefühl. Aber Bequemlichkeit ist eine Seuche, das ist leider so. Und wir alle sind ja anheimgefallen. Das hat dann immer sowas Predigerhaftes. Dann sitzt du da und denkst nur noch, du besitzt in der Kirche und einer erzählt dir, wie scheiße du bist. Aber Tatsache ist, es bröckelt an allen Ecken und Enden.
Das ist wirklich so. Naja, aber ich meine, es ist ja besser, wenn man sieht, was alles schlecht läuft, als wenn man da nur sitzt und von allen Ecken und Enden beschissen wird und einfach gar nichts mitkriegt. Also insofern haben wir hier schon auch die Aufgabe, so ein bisschen zur Aufklärung beizutragen. Also es gab ja durchaus Zeiten, wo die Leute einfach zu Hause gesessen haben, ihnen ist erzählt worden, alles ist scheiße und du bist schuld. Ja, und dann haben die halt ihr Leben so gebracht. Dann find ich es doch besser, wenn wir ab und zu mal Chaosradio haben, wo uns die Leute erzählen, warum alles schlecht ist und was wir dagegen tun können.
Ja, wenigstens gutes Karma machen. Das machen wir gleich noch anderthalb Stunden weiter. Jetzt gibt es erstmal Nachrichten hier auf Fritz.
Fritz in Berlin.
Dann 102, 6.
Wir haben es 22.31 Uhr.
Fritz in Stuttgart.
Mit dem Wetter nachts wird es neblig, die Temperaturen sinken auf 2 bis minus 2 Grad. Morgen ist es dann bedeckt und trübe bei 4 bis 8 Grad. Und oben drauf gibt es noch eine wunderbare Packung Sprühregen. Jetzt die Meldungen mit Bastian Berner.
Deutschland will den USA bei einem Angriff auf den Irak Überflug und Transitrechte gewähren. Bundeskanzler Schröder sagte, eine direkte militärische Unterstützung werde es aber nicht geben. Nur Israel werde aus moralischen Gründen Luftabwehrraketen und Truppentransporter des Typs Fuchs erhalten. Die UNO-Waffeninspektoren haben mit ihren Kontrollen im Irak begonnen. Sie durchsuchten heute zwei Militäranlagen und eine Fabrik in der Umgebung von Bagdad. UNO-Generalsekretär Anan sprach von einem guten Staat. Der FDP-Politiker Jürgen Möllemann will aus seiner Partei nicht freiwillig austreten. Er werde sich dem Druck der Parteiführung nicht beugen, sagte Möllemann in mehreren Interviews. Er denkt nach eigenen Angaben darüber nach, eine neue liberale Partei zu gründen. Die islamistische Vereinigung Kalifatstaat bleibt verboten. Das Bundesverwaltungsgericht bestätigte am Abend eine Entscheidung der Bundesregierung. Nach Ansicht der Richter hat der Verein sowohl gegen die demokratische Grundordnung als auch gegen das Rechtsstaatprinzip und die Achtung der Menschenwürde verstoßen. Und zum Sport in der Zwischenrunde der Fußball Champions League hat Bayer Leverkusen gegen den FC Barcelona 1 zu 2 verloren. Unterverkehrer Fritz, wir haben keine Meldungen, also gute Fahrt.
Sie ist unterwegs, sie macht Spaß und ganz bestimmt irgendwann kommt sie auch zu dir.
Freitag 22 Uhr im Echtkastanienhof in Bühle Gure mit den Fritz DJs Anja und René und Special Guest Studio 45.
Und ihr hört das Chaos-Radio Fritz, der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Er hat immer Chaosradio-Arben, drei Stunden Talk über Themen, die die Welt wirklich bewegen, nämlich die, die im Hintergrund den Hebel ansetzen. Und das ist leider Gottes mal wieder. Man denkt ja, man müsse eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr drüber reden. Aber es ist Microsoft und zusammen mit einem Hebelnamen, nämlich Intel und es geht um TCPA, Palladium. TCPA ist das neue System, was auf uns zukommt, im Grunde in den neuen Windows-Generation, also den neuen Betriebssystem-Generation. Und was das macht, das können wir ja nochmal ganz kurz zusammenfassen, weil wir dann auch zu einem neuen Funktionspunkt dieser ganzen Sache übergehen möchten, mit dem Studio Felix und... Ich hatte gerade irgendwie wieder einen anderen Namen im Kopf. Und Malodki, meinen Namen, das kann ich, na Gott sei Dank kann ich das noch. Siehst du, hier ist der Zettel nämlich. Und ja, Felix, du wolltest nochmal ganz kurz einleiten in das Thema für diejenigen, die vielleicht gerade erst dazuschalten.
Hallo, hallo. Genau, TCPA ist eine neue Infrastruktur für PCs, die mit Verschlüsselung dafür sorgen soll, dass das Betriebssystem überhaupt nur dann gebootet wird, wenn es in einer Datenbank, die in der Hardware drin steht unter anderem, und die natürlich über das Internet geupdatet werden soll, wenn da die Prüfsumme drin steht. Also die Idee ist sozusagen, dass das BIOS guckt, ist das überhaupt das richtige Windows, oder hat da jemand rummanipuliert und der weigert sich dann, das zu booten, wenn es nicht das richtige Windows ist. Und es geht dann weiter. Wenn Windows gebootet ist, kann der mit der Hardware erkennen, ist dieser Treiber denn überhaupt okay? Oder ist das vielleicht ein Debugger? Also das heißt, das wird eine Infrastruktur geschaffen, mit der, sagen wir, Raubkopierte oder manipulierte Software erkannt werden soll. Und insbesondere ist es so, wenn ich in einem System mit TCPA eine nicht vertrauenswürdige oder unbekannte Applikation starte, dass das System dann allen vertrauenswürdigen Applikationen sagt, also wie zum Beispiel Ver.T. Hallo, da kommt jetzt gerade was, was möglicherweise bösartig ist. Und Ver.T. kann dann erstmal seinen Speicher löschen, sich beenden. Und am Ende, erst wenn alle sich beendet haben, dann wird die neue Applikation gestartet. Und das heißt, insbesondere eben für Online-Spieler, sagen wir mal, das Spiel ist eben eine vertrauenswürdige Applikation. Wenn ich einen Trainer starte oder irgendeinen Map-Hack, der vorhin erwähnt wurde, dann würde das Spiel ein Signal kriegen, würde sich beenden. Und Online-Cheating wäre sozusagen beendet. Aber wenn man jetzt ein bisschen mehr darüber nachdenkt, oder ein paar Szenarien sich überlegt, dann kann man so ein paar Einblicke in das System gewinnen. Also nehmen wir mal an, der Media Player, der bei Windows mitgeliefert ist, da ist irgendwann ein Bug drin. Da ist ein Bug drin, der so krass ist, dass man damit eben doch kopieren kann. Also genau das, was eigentlich verhindert werden soll, würde doch möglich sein. Was würde man tun, um zu verhindern, dass die Leute eben mit diesem Bug ihre ganzen Sachen kopieren? Und die Lösung dafür ist, dass es eine sogenannte schwarze Liste gibt, die über Internet geupdatet wird. Also es gibt nicht nur eine Liste mit vertrauenswürdigen Applikationen, sondern es gibt auch eine Liste mit unvertrauenswürdigen Applikationen. Die Idee ist, was jetzt bei Windows XP zum Beispiel passiert, dass Seriennummern im Netz veröffentlicht werden. Irgendwelche Leute kaufen das und veröffentlichen ihre Seriennummer, und dann kann im Grunde jeder andere auch mit dieser Seriennummer sich da sein Windows registrieren. Und das soll eben verhindert werden. Und das kann man tun, indem man die Seriennummer, oder gleich wenn die Raubkopie bei Microsoft eben auch auftaucht, dann kann man gleich die Raubkopie komplett eintragen in die schwarze Liste. Und dann würde ein TCPA-Computer sich komplett weigern, diese Software zu starten.
Also diese schwarze Liste funktioniert so, dass eine eindeutige Identifizierung dieses Stück Software oder auch dieses Stück Content, zum Beispiel ein Text, der irgendwie missliebig ist, oder ein Artikel, oder ein Bild, was irgendwie missliebig ist, die werden halt über eine sogenannte Hash-Funktion, eine dadurch identifizierbare Hash-Funktion, ist ein mathematisches Verfahren, mit dem ich eine eindeutige Nummer errechnen kann, die spezifisch für dieses Stück Software oder dieses Stück Content ist, ein Stück Musik zum Beispiel, diesen Artikel, sodass, wenn dieses Stück Software oder Musik auf diesen Computer kommt, dann wird dieser Hash ausgerechnet, das heißt also diese eindeutige Identifizierung dieses Stückes Content, und wird dann mit der schwarzen Liste verglichen, ob diese Hash-Funktion auf dieser Liste steht. Und wenn das so ist, dann wird dieser Inhalt halt auch schlicht gelöscht oder kopiert oder weitergemeldet, je nachdem, was der Hersteller vorgesehen hat.
Also das System weigert sich im Zweifelsfall. Die Idee ist jetzt, mit dem Media Player und dem Bug, dass Microsoft sagen könnte, wir bringen Update raus und wir tun die alte Version von dem Media Player auf die schwarze Liste. Und was dann passiert, ist, dass jemand, der die Version mit dem Bug aufrufen möchte, der kriegt dann gesagt, geht nicht, musst du updaten.
Ah, das ist ja toll.
Und damit sorgen die dann automatisch auch dafür, dass ich immer neues Hardware brauche, weil sonst ist mein System ja im Konsolat.
Aber das ist jetzt eher von Intel die Verschwörungstheorie und nicht von Microsoft. Aber die Idee ist jedenfalls klar, der Kunde wird dazu gezwungen, abzudaten, damit eben Software mit Bugs keine Chance hat. So was jetzt Frank gesagt hat, eindeutig, das ist zwar in der Praxis so, aber nicht unbedingt zwingend. Also es ist so, dass der Hash-Wert schon weniger als groß ist als die Daten, aus denen ich sie berechne. Das heißt rein theoretisch ist es möglich, dass es eine Kollision gibt. Also dass zwei Programme den gleichen Hash-Wert haben. Das ist verschwinden unwahrscheinlich. Aber man muss sich schon fragen, was passiert, wenn es dann doch mal irgendwann auftreten sollte. Also nehmen wir mal an, ich finde ein Programm, oder ich kann, es gelingt mir, ein Dokument zu erzeugen, was die gleiche Hash-Summe hat wie, sagen wir, Windows. Das wäre so der schlimmste Angriff auf TCPA, der mir persönlich eingefallen ist. Nehmen wir mal an, es gelingt mir so ein Bild zu erzeugen, und in dem Bild steht drin, Microsoft ist scheiße. Nehmen wir mal an, dieses Bild würde ich dann Microsoft e-mailen, und die tun es auf ihre schwarze Liste. Dann könnte kein Rechner mehr Windows booten. Weil das BIOS anhand der schwarzen Liste prüft, ist denn das System sauber. Also das wäre so eine Sache, die man sich mal in Ruhe überlegen muss. Was man heute machen würde, wenn ein System nicht mehr booten will, ist, dass man eben eine Boot-CD reintut. Jetzt habe ich aber an den Media Player erwähnt. Selbstverständlich kann auch das Windows auf der CD eine alte Version sein, von dem es inzwischen Updates gibt, und dann würde sich der Computer auch weigern, von dieser CD zu booten.
Aber Moment!
Hat der dann... Achso. Das wird dann so funktionieren, dass sozusagen diese schwarze Liste schon in einen Hardware-Part im Prozessor oder irgendwo gehanden wird und da ist dann die aktuelle schwarze Liste.
Es gibt ein bisschen Speicher an der Hardware und die wird eben ab und zu geupdatet. Also jetzt muss man sich überlegen, das wäre sozusagen der absolute Oberdatengau, wenn die Checksumme von Windows in dieser schwarzen Liste erschien. Denn wenn man da was gegen tun könnte, wäre das ein Designfehler bei TCPA. Also nehmen wir mal alles... Ich könnte mit einer Bootes-Kette an meinem Windows-Rom manipulieren, sodass da wieder eine andere schwarze Liste steht. Wenn ich das könnte, könnte ich das auch benutzen, um den Schutz normal zu umgehen, indem ich halt die Applikation, sagen wir, den Trainer, den ich habe, aus der schwarzen Liste rausnehme. Ja, also diese Manipulation darf gar nicht möglich sein, sonst ist das System von vornherein unsicher.
Aber ich meine, Sekunde mal, wenn Microsoft übers Internet beziehungsweise über sein eigenes Betriebssystem in der Lage sein soll, das Ding innerhalb eines bestimmten Hardware-Segments oder was auch immer abzudaten, dann muss es ja sowas sein, was wie das BIOS funktioniert oder was wie ein Flash-Rom funktioniert, und das könnte ich doch dann im Grunde auch updaten oder ähnliches.
Ja, also theoretisch schon. Es ist ja im Grunde auch mit Smart Cards so, dass man die im Grunde theoretisch beschreiben kann. Aber da ist so ein kleines Mini-Betriebssystem drauf, was sich eben Updates anzunehmen weigert, wenn man sich nicht selber irgendwie authentisieren kann. So und der Punkt ist jetzt, dass Windows, der sich authentisieren wollte, auf der schwarzen Liste drauf steht. Also wenn, man muss sich halt überlegen, dass dieser Angriff auch nur theoretisch denkbar ist, ist im Grunde schon ein Grund, warum das ganze System zum Scheitern verurteilt ist. Denn wenn das tatsächlich mal eines Tages passiert, dann würde eben auf der gesamten Welt die Windows-PCs nicht mehr booten können und man kann sie auch nicht reparieren, indem man eine andere Festplatte oder so reintut. Sondern man muss dann eben den PC wegschmeißen oder eben von einem Experten reparieren lassen.
Aber meinst du nicht, dass die ein paar Prüf-Summen haben von den Programmen, von denen sie wissen, dass die 100% funktionieren und die sind dann soweit geschützt, dass dann, wenn jemand versucht, so was, was da eben halt extra dafür programmiert worden ist, auf die schwarze Liste zu setzen, dass das dann im Endeffekt nicht funktionieren will?
Na also, wenn sie das hier gehört haben, sind sie vielleicht so schlau.
Aber wir haben ja auch 5 Jahre verpasst, diese Lizenz anzumelden.
Nein, also man muss ja auch mal noch ein paar andere Sachen sagen. Historisch gesehen ist Microsoft so das unsicherste Unternehmen, was überhaupt gibt. Es gibt mindestens 4 dokumentierte Fälle, wo Microsoft sogar zugegeben hat, dass Hacker in ihrem Netz waren und sogar teilweise Zugriff auf Development Server hatten, wo eben der Source Code zur Windows rumliegt. Das ist passiert und eines Tages hat jemand geschafft, sich ein Zertifikat bei Virisign zu holen, im Namen von Microsoft und konnte damit eben auch Software unterschreiben. Das heißt, alle Teile, die nötig wären, um diesen Angriff durchzuführen, gab es schon mal bei Microsoft. Also man muss sich vorstellen, was ich als Regierung, oder noch schlimmer, das US-Militär setze. Zum Beispiel flächendeckend Windows ein. Jetzt muss man sich mal vorstellen, was passiert, wenn in einem Krieg jemand sich Zugang zu der Microsoft-Zertifikatsstelle besorgt und diesen Angriff durchführt. Dann werden einfach die kompletten Kriegsschiffe einfach mal im Wasser wie tote Enten liegen. Das hast du übrigens auch schon mal gegeben.
Na gut, das war dann aber eher ein Windows-Problem.
Aus anderem Grund.
Genauso kann man sich natürlich auch vorstellen, dass, sagen wir mal, dass die US Government plötzlich beschließt, die irakische Version von Windows zu invalidieren.
Genau.
Um halt einfach mal die Infrastruktur in einem Zielland runterzufahren. Also das heißt, man sieht schon, das Kernproblem ist, dass da halt wieder mal zu viel Macht in einer Hand konzentriert wird, also zu viel zu viel Einflussnahmemöglichkeit halt auf einem Punkt konzentriert wird, der dann natürlich auch missbraucht werden kann.
Gut, also vielleicht noch, um das mal so ein bisschen klarer zu machen, wenn im Moment irgendeine Shareware sagt, ich laufe nur bis zum Tag so und so, oder wenn ein Programm sagt, ich laufe nur, wenn du dich bis zum so und so viel in ein Update einspielst, was die meisten Leute dann machen oder zumindest in Erinnerung ziehen, ist, dass sie halt die Systemzeit zurücksetzen. Ja, so eine typische Maßnahme. Da haben die TCPA Leute auch dran gedacht und haben eine vertrauenswürdige Systemzeit definiert. Also in dem Chip, in dem TCPA ist nochmal eine eigene Systemuhr und die kann man nur updaten mit signierten Zeitupdates. Und dafür soll es dann eben Server im Internet geben. Ja, also das heißt, die Systemzeit zurückstellen läuft nicht.
Was da alles schiebt, ne?
Ja, man muss sich das vorstellen. Also im Grunde so an die offensichtlichen Sachen, so ein paar von ihnen haben sie gedacht. Aber das heißt eben auch, wenn ich die Systemzeit nicht zurückstellen kann, kann ich auch nicht mal eben eine alte schwarze Liste einspielen ins System. Also so die Rettungsmethoden, die ich jetzt mal als Administrator in Erwägung ziehen würde, wenn mein System so im Angriff zu einem Opfer fällt, die gibt es halt einfach nicht.
Soweit ein weiteres Häppchen resignative Basisinformationen im Chaosradio und ihr seid natürlich angehalten, das zu kommentieren oder zu dekommentieren. 0331 77 97 1 1 0. Am Telefon ist der Guido. Na, Guido? Entschuldige, ich hätte dich glaube ich vorhin kurz rausgeworfen. Das lag ja in der Telefonanlage. Aber du hast es ja wieder geschafft.
Na ja, jetzt könnte ich mir inzwischen, müsste ich mir jetzt doch Musik raubkopieren, weil ich mir die CD morgen nicht mehr kaufen kann. Das Geld ist ja an der Telefonrechnung. Ein Thema ist noch nicht beleuchtet worden. Und zwar ist ja Microsoft vor zwei Wochen aus dem Stinger Projekt bei Zendu rausgeflogen. Bei dem Smartphone. Und das heißt ja, was für eine Strategie müsste jetzt Microsoft verfolgen, dass jetzt 7650 Smartphone Nokia Benutzer oder zukünftige Sony Ericsson P800 Benutzer, die auf ihrem Handy auch inzwischen Word Dokumente, Powerpoint, Präsentation oder Excel Sheets bearbeiten können. Wie sollten denn da die einzelnen Daten zertifiziert, lizenziert oder trastet gemacht werden?
Also zu diesem Thema Send-No, es ist so, dass alle Leute fragten sich natürlich, warum man alles in der Welt hat. Send-No, Send-No ist eine kleine englische Firma, die ein Mobiltelefon auf der Basis von dem Windows CE für Mobiltelefone entwickelt hatte. Warum um alles in der Welt haben die nun kurz vor der Produkteinführung gesagt, sie lassen das mit dem Windows für Mobiltelefone lieber. Man nehmt stattdessen dieses Produkt von Nokia. Ich hab da auch keine Antwort vor, nur eine böse Theorie, dass nämlich Nokia gewartet hat, bis sie fertig waren, und dann noch ein Patent aus der Tasche gezogen hat. Was sie dann noch hatten rumliegen lassen. Also es gibt so ein paar Hinweise, die das andeuten. Was die Durchsetzung von TCPA auf mobilen Endgeräten betrifft, ist es so, dass der wahrscheinlichste Weg, dieses zu tun, vermutlich über die ARM Prozessoren ist. Wenn du dir anguckst, was du heutzutage in mobilen Geräten findest, findest du exklusiv eigentlich ARM und X-Scale Prozessoren. Was anderes sind in den neuen Geräten eigentlich nicht mehr drin.
Und X-Scale ist auch ARM vielleicht als Andeutung.
Genau, X-Scale ist sozusagen nur der aufgebordete ARM, der auf Ihren Tagzahlen läuft, aber in seinem Abgurt unterstützt. Die kommen halt auch von Intel. Und es gibt halt auch schon seit längerem Planungen Digital Rights Management, also Möglichkeiten zum Kopieren von Software und zum Beispiel auch von Klingeltönen auf Mobiltelefonen unterbinden zu können, diese Dinge einzubauen. Soweit ich die Roadmap von Intel richtig im Kopf habe, sollen auch Anfang 2004 die ersten ARM-Prozessoren mit Möglichkeiten zum Schutz von Software auf diesen Geräten unterwegs sein. Das Problem, was wir da halt haben werden, ist, dass da das Sicherheitsargument möglicherweise sogar ziehen wird, weil diese Mobiltelefone sind halt extrem ungeschützt. Da kann man halt ziemlich viele Sauereien mitmachen. Also es gibt halt Dutzende Möglichkeiten, zum Beispiel Viren mit MMSen zu verschicken, wenn man weiß, wie das geht. Und wenn sie halt glaubwürdig machen können, dass man mit Hilfe von so Co-Zahnung-Technologien diese Dinge unterwinden kann auf der Prozessorebene, dann haben sie tatsächlich dafür auch einen richtigen Markt. Was jetzt Nokia betrifft, ist es so, dass die ja zum Glück Microsoft nicht besonders freundlich gesinnt sind, sodass es da eine gewisse Hoffnung gibt, dass der Markt sich dann nicht ganz so krass entwickelt wie im PC.
Die Hoffnung zerstöre sich aber in dem Moment, wenn ich mit dem PC synchronisieren will, wenn ich irgendwelche Bilder, die ich von irgendjemanden geschossen habe, demjenigen schicken will, per MMS, oder erst auf dem PC bearbeiten will, oder im Handy schon mit einer gewissen Software bearbeite. Es gibt ja schon Programme, wenn ich ein Bild geschossen habe mit dem Nokia-Telefon, dass ich das im Telefon schon nachbearbeiten kann. Somit ist es mein Bild, ich hab das Recht drauf, jetzt indirekt gesagt. Und wo könnt ihr das Bild jetzt überall hinschicken? Auf mein PC, auf einen anderen PC?
Ich denke nicht, dass sie das verhindern werden, weil gerade diese Bilder von einem Telefon zum anderen schicken und Telefon zu PC usw. sofort, ist ja ziemlich wesentlich für ihre Aussicht, in der Geld zu machen in dem Markt. Insofern glaube ich nicht, dass sie an dem konkreten Punkt ansetzen werden, wo ich denke, dass sie sicherlich ansetzen werden, ist Kopierschutz für Software. Also wenn du dir zum Beispiel so einen P800 anguckst, da kannst du halt irgendwie Doom drauf zocken. Da gibt es Landkarten-Applikationen für, da gibt es jede Menge Software für. Das handelt sich hier um... Na, diese interessanterweise sind diese Symbian-Clones von Textverarbeitung usw. und so weiter, und sofort Tabellenkalkulation, sind ja keine Microsoft-Produkte, sondern die sind ja von Symbian tatsächlich programmiert. Es ist nur so, dass sie mit Microsoft irgendein Cross-Licensing-Abkommen für die Datenformate haben, aber die erstrecken sich soweit, ich weiß auch schon nicht mehr, auf die neueren aus Office Formate. Also da ist es schon so, dass sie da sicherlich irgendeinen Weg finden werden. Meine Vermutung ist tatsächlich sogar, dass wir eher noch auf den mobilen Endgeräten, so dass wir TCPA und Palladium sehen werden, als auf den PCs, weil es geschlossene Plattformen sind. Also da haben die Leute nicht dieses Rumspielbedürfnis, noch nicht dieses Gefühl, dass sie damit machen können, was sie wollen, den Content darauf hin und her schieben können, wie sie wollen und so weiter und so fort. So ein Telefon wird ja mehr als geschlossenes Gerät wahrgenommen, dass man vielleicht mal ein bisschen Software in meinem Klingelton drauf lädt, vor allem nicht so über den PC, wo man jeden Tag Sachen hin und her ist.
Inwieweit hat der Sony schon was gemacht? Weil bei dem Sony EF-5400, der ist ja weiter mit dem Memory Stick von Sony. Und bekannt ist ja, dass bei der Sony PlayStation Direct dieser Memory Stick ja Media Gate geschützt ist.
Sony hat ja verschiedene Digital Roads Management Technologien in den Memory Sticks integriert. Über das P800 kann man noch nicht so viel sagen, was diesen Aspekt betrifft, weil naja, sie hoffen ja gerade, dass sie es zum Weihnachtsgeschäft irgendwie rauskriegen, aber soweit ich weiß, ist die Software noch nicht gänzlich fertig, die darauf läuft. Also die Prototypen, die ich in der Hand hatte, die waren so zwei Monate alt ungefähr, die Software. Und da war von DRM-Modulen noch nicht so viel zu sehen, wo allerdings schon jede Menge von zu sehen war, waren so Sachen wie Code Signing und solche Dinge. Also bei Nokia betreibt es ja auch sehr extensiv auf den Summingeräten, dass man Applikationen auf den Dingern nur starten kann, also wenn es so eingestellt ist von Benutzer, die halt das richtige Signing haben. Das heißt also vom Hersteller abgesegnet sind oder in einem Key abgesegnet sind, der vom Hersteller an den Softwarelieferanten vergeben wurde.
Nicht ganz so richtig. Also wenn ich Programme auf dem 7650 installiere, werde ich darauf hingewiesen, dass die Signatur nicht bekannt ist oder dass sie nicht vertrauenswürdig ist und ob ich trotzdem installieren möchte.
Und ich kann noch installieren. Momentan ist es so, dass es eine Useroption ist, ob du dem vertraust oder nicht. Der Schritt ist natürlich nicht weit, einfach diese Abfrage wegzulassen.
Ja, da konnten Felix nicht so viel mit anzufangen, aber das ist der Reboot fürs Hören, meine Damen und Herren, akustischerweise, damit man jetzt nochmal neu ansetzen kann für das Thema. Wir haben nämlich noch eine gute Stunde Zeit im Chaosradio hier auf Fritz. Felix und Frank vom Chaosradio hier links und rechts von mir und ich quasi in der Mitte von mir selber, Max mein Name. Das Thema heute Abend TCPA und was alles dranhängt. Und wollen wir einfach mal weiter, weil jetzt gerade eben sind eure Anrufe recht zahlreich als Meinung dazu, was ihr davon haltet, von so ner geschützten Plattform in allen Belangen, die von Windows angestrebt wird und von Intel und von allen anderen, die auf der Liste sind auch, und das sind scheinbar alle, was ihr davon haltet. 0331 77 97 110, die Nummer. Und am Telefon ist der Jakob.
Und zwar wollte ich was sagen zu den Interessen seitens der Musikindustrie und der Filmindustrie, die ja dadurch eigentlich auch gar nicht richtig vertreten werden. Man ist ja schon so weit, dass man mit den Rechnern DVDs und CDs brennen kann. CDs sind ja schon lange. Und diese Rechner werden es ja eigentlich in zehn Jahren immer noch tun. Also insofern wird da nicht so viel, werden die da nicht viel von haben.
Also die Methode, wie sie dieses Problem bei TCPA angehen, ist folgende, was sie sich vorstellen. Ist, dass neue DVDs, die ausgeliefert werden, in einer Art und Weise verschlüsselt sind, die es unmöglich macht, irgendwo an den Rohdatenstrom auf dieser DVD zu kommen. Das heißt, das System, wenn es hochfährt, und du sagst, du willst jetzt hier eine DVD angucken, startet einen abgesicherten Player, der erst mal guckt, ob es in diesem System irgendwelche verdächtig aussehende Software gibt und die erst mal rausschmeißt. Und dieses TCPA geht so weit bis in die Grafikkarten rein. Das heißt also, die haben sich tatsächlich Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie sie sicherstellen können, dass man das Signal nicht aus den Grafikkarten und wie man das Signal nicht aus den Soundkarten abgreifen kann. Das einzige, was du dann tatsächlich noch tun kannst, ist das analog Video kopieren und wieder zu redigitalisieren. Das ist dann auch das einzige, was dir tatsächlich übrig bleibt, wenn da nicht schon wieder Makrovision drauf ist, dann brauchst du wieder Makrovisons, Decoder und so weiter und so fort.
Aber wenn die die Rohdatenströme verschlüsseln, dann müssten sie ja auch die ganzen Geräte, die die ganzen Hardware-Geräte umbauen. Also nochmal eine neue Generation von DVD-Playern und CD-Playern.
Ich glaube, da haben die keinen Schmerz mit das zu tun.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das so durchkriegen.
Oh Gott, ich mal überlegen, was ein DVD-Player kostet.
Aber wenn Deutschland nur deswegen neuen DVD-Player kaufen muss, denke ich schon, dass es dann...
Es wird natürlich neue Features geben und irgendwie was auch immer.
Ja und guck, liest doch mal, da steht drin, dass die nächsten DVDs werden mit blauen Lasern sein, da wird viel mehr Platz sein, da haben wir dann vielleicht HDTV, wenn das dann noch mal eines Tages kommt, und mehr Features und noch einen Track mit dem koreanischen Übersetzung von dem Kommentar des Regisseurs. Also ich meine, es ist schon so, dass es da durchaus noch Erweiterungsmöglichkeiten mit der DVD gibt, das ist ja nur auch schon ein paar Jahre alt. Ja genau, und DVD-Audio, also es gibt tausend neue Standards, die da gerade in Anleitung sind.
Das ist natürlich insofern recht, als dass die installierte Basis an DVD-Playern schon ein gewisses Hindernis darstellt. Aber wenn du zum Beispiel mal anguckst, was bei CDs passiert, da machen sie es ja genau so, momentan mit dem Kopierschutz, dass man die CDs zwar im normalen CD-Player abspielen kann, aber zum Beispiel nicht mehr auf dem PC. So, indem sie halt Spezifika ausnutzen, die halt unterschiedlich sind zwischen den Playern in PCs und in diesen Hardware, also diesen ganz normalen Stint-Allow-CD-Playern. Und es ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass es da einen ähnlichen Trend geben wird. Sie werden halt diese Updates dafür Jahre im Voraus einführen, um halt sicherzustellen, dass sie irgendwie zwei, drei Jahre Zeit haben, bis die Leute sich in der Regel sowieso einen neuen Player gekauft haben, der halt irgendwas Neues kann. Also zum Beispiel, ich würde mir sofort einen neuen DVD-Player kaufen, wenn das Ding endlich Divix abspielen kann. Und wahrscheinlich handel ich mir dann in dem Augenblick halt irgendwie schon wieder eine tolle DRM-Technologie ein. Diese Konsumerelektronik ist mittlerweile so unglaublich billig geworden, dass die Update-Zyklen nicht mehr als zwei oder drei Jahre sind. Hast du noch irgendein wirkliches Konsumergerät, das irgendwie älter ist als drei oder vier Jahre? Das ist irgendwie schon echt selten geworden.
Pass auf, jetzt ruft jemand mit einem Plattenspieler an. Hebt sie euch auf.
Es kann auch sein, dass dann auch Geräte rauskommen, die dann auch wieder mehrere Sachen unterstützen. So wie diese DVD-Plates CD-RWs und sonst was unterstützen, was die Musikindustrie ja auch nicht irgendwie hätte machen müssen. So kann es ja dann auch sein, dass sich wieder irgendwelche findigen Firmen auftun, die dann immer freundlicher sind.
Natürlich wird es immer Firmen wie Amakava oder Flower Power Enterprises irgendwo in, keine Ahnung wo geben, die halt Geräte herstellen, mit denen man halt Raubkopierte oder geback-upte Medien abspielen kann. Nur wird halt, also das Ziel, was die Industrie da verfolgt an dieser Stelle, ist ja die Anzahl von kopierbaren Medien zu senken. Also du musst ja sozusagen das Zeug irgendwie erst mal rauskriegen aus diesem Verschlüsselungsgewusel, bevor du es dir auf eine DVD brennen kannst, auf eine CD brennen kannst und so weiter und so fort. Und was sie halt versuchen, ist, sie können natürlich nie verhindern, dass man es über den analogen Weg nochmal kopiert. Also dass man es halt einfach redigitalisiert, nachdem man es abgespielt hat. Da gibt es momentan keine Technik auf dem Markt, die das Zufall sich verhindern kann. Nur sinkt dabei natürlich die Qualität dramatisch. Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, okay, ist mir egal. Ich gucke sowieso nur die im Kino abgefilmten James Bond Filme, die irgendwie wackeln und wo Leute vorne durchs Bild rennen. Hauptsache, ich habe sie vor allen anderen. Okay, dann ist es in Ordnung. Nur in dem Augenblick, wo man ein bisschen mehr Qualität will, hat man halt genau das Problem, dass man nur auf den Content von der Industrie zugreifen kann.
Also man sollte vielleicht sagen, dass wir das nicht grundsätzlich schlecht finden, was die Contentindustrie da macht. Denn wir als TTC haben unter anderem das Ziel, kreative Techniknutzung zu fördern. Und wenn man sieht, wie kreativ gewisse Hersteller mit den DVD- und CD-Standards umgehen, das ist schon durchaus würdigenswert. Aber grundsätzlich ist es eben so, dass die durchaus auch mal Sachen tun, die nicht im Standard stehen. Also die aber darauf setzen, dass bestehende Software sich an den Standard hält oder bestehende Player, so funktioniert der Kopierschutz im Moment, dass Leute, die sich an den Standard halten, irgendwie es nicht abspielen können, aber dass sie eben gezielt Bugs in ihren eigenen Player haben, die dann eben doch das so abspielen, wie es gehen soll. Und letztendlich kann man gegen sowas auch nichts tun. Weil es gibt ja noch den anderen Hebel, nämlich dass man das DVD-Logo als Playerhersteller nur kriegt, wenn man sowas wie Markovision und CSS implementiert. Und ähnlich ist es so, dass die sagen könnten, wir geben dir jetzt das Logo für DVD nicht, wenn du nicht den Standard richtig implementierst. Und der Kopierschutz setzt dann eben aber doch darauf aus, dass man ihn falsch implementiert. Also es gibt da durchaus Möglichkeiten wie die bestehenden Kartelle und sowas ist es die DVD. Das DVD Konsortium ist durchaus so ein Kartell aus den großen Content Herstellern und eben Leute wie Sony, Panasonic, eben so große. Da sind kaum kleine drin. Also Yammer Cover ist glaube ich nicht drin. Aber jedenfalls, das heißt, es gibt da durchaus letztendlich sind viele von diesen Maßnahmen und TCPA im Grunde auch, sind Kartell-Erhaltungsmaßnahmen von großen Firmen, die ansonsten eben nicht konkurrenzfähig wären.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, diese Contentnummer, viele Leute glauben ja immer, dass Contentverwaltung, also dieser Digital Rights Management Bereich, im Contentbereich, was man sich so downloaden kann, was man sich im Internet angucken kann, dass das noch alles relativ unwichtig ist und dass es sich halt nur auf sowas erstreckt, wie DVDs, CDs und ähnliches. Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin relativ beunruhigt über die Zunahme von sowas wie Bezahlstrukturen bei den Seiten, die früher alle so dermaßen umsonst waren, dass sie es jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr sind. Gerade insbesondere bei Spieleseiten oder ähnliches, wenn man Updates runterladen will. Man kriegt für bestimmte Spiele, die bestimmte Verträge eingehen, zum Beispiel keine Updates mehr runtergeladen. Wenn man sich nicht irgendwo bei International Gaming Network und was weiß ich nicht, was einloggt.
Vor allem steht auf der Packung Free Online Gaming. Das finde ich den Oberhammer darauf, dass sie das bewerben, als sei es kostenlos.
Und ich muss mich wirklich anstrengen, um irgendwo eine Stelle zu finden, wo ich das einfach mal direkt runterladen kann, ohne anzugeben zu müssen, wo ich wohne, welche Postleitzahl ich habe und ähnliches. Und dann stehen da solche Sachen, da kann ich mich dann anmelden. Aber wenn ich ein paar Daten weglasse, das darf ich dann tun, dann denke ich, wow, die sind ja kulland. Und dann stelle ich fest, ja, dann geben die mir nur die Server zur Verfügung, wo ich in einer virtuellen Reihenfolge mit anderen Usern stehe, sodass ich erst in 45 Minuten mit meinem Download beginnen kann. Da freut sich der Mensch.
Also vielleicht, was wir auch noch sagen sollten, wir fühlen uns ja durchaus geschmeichelt, wenn wir so hören, dass die Grundeinstellung im Volk ist. Ja, das wird schon jemand knacken und ich mach mir da jetzt keine Sorgen. Und die Hacker, die haben das ja noch immer hingekriegt. Leute, ihr müsst euch da schon trotzdem ein bisschen Sorgen machen. Denn letztendlich wird es irgendwann einfach mal so richtig verboten sein, die Sachen zu knacken. Und wenn die Bundesregierung anfängt, ihren europäischen Verpflichtungen nachzukommen und die Hacker auch mal so richtig zu inhaftieren, wie da den Kopierschutz umgehen, dann sieht das Mau aus. Also da muss jetzt tatsächlich auf rechtlicher und politischer Ebene was gemacht werden, damit es nicht so weit kommt.
Aber inwiefern ist es denn möglich, weil du schon gesagt hast, dass es relativ schwierig ist, Felix, sich auf der europäischen Ebene zu engagieren, inwiefern kann ich da überhaupt was reißen, dass die darauf aufmerksam werden, dass ich das jetzt grundsätzlich in europäischem Maßstab nicht möchte?
Na, man kann auf jeden Fall seine Stimme hörbar machen, indem man einen Brief zu seinen Abgeordneten schickt. Es ist sogar so, dass einige EU-Abgeordnete oder relativ viele auch eine eigene Homepage haben und da kann man sogar per E-Mail oder per Fax hinschreiben. Und die meisten Abgeordneten sind ja nicht so, dass die sagen, ich will jetzt meine Wähler ärgern, deswegen versuche ich jetzt, die Gesetze durchzubringen, die möglichst viel Schaden anrichten, sondern wenn man denen deutlich genug mitteilt, dass man das nicht haben will, dann sind die auch bereit, dagegen zu argumentieren. Also um das mal so zu schildern, die meisten Abstimmungen auf EU-Ebene und im Bundestag natürlich auch, sind so das von denen, was ich 500 Leute sind, überhaupt nur 30 da. Und ein paar gucken noch auf ihrem Monitor zu und wenn die nicht mitkriegen, dass das ein wichtiges Problem ist, was sie da gerade abstimmen, dann sind die einfach nicht da. Ja und dementsprechend ist das natürlich, dass man da als Wähler auch in der Pflicht ist, seinen Politikern mitzuteilen, an welchen Problemen man interessiert ist.
Ja gut, aber wenn die schon nicht wissen, dass das ein wichtiges Problem ist, dann wissen erfahrungsgemäß auch die Leute, die medial dahinter stehen, die Journalisten nicht, dass das ein wichtiges Problem ist, dann wissen wir, die wir ja nicht unbedingt die ganzen Tage vom Parlament sitzen als Privatperson, erst recht nicht, dass da gerade ein wichtiges Problem anliegt. Und wie soll ich das dann wissen?
Ja, deswegen machen wir die Radiosendung unter anderem.
Ach, das ist dieses Tutschnap-Argument.
Genau, deswegen sind wir hier, damit ihr das mitkriegt zuhause und damit ihr jetzt euren Hintern hochkriegt und was tut.
Andreas ist am Telefon. Hallo Andreas.
Ja, hallo.
Na, Moment. Oh, der hat aber jemand den Hintern hochgekriegt.
Oh, dieser Alarm hier. Der hat zum einen aus der Leitung rausgeflogen, aber jetzt hat es geklappt.
Hi, na, Abend.
Und ich wollte noch sagen, ich hab einen Platenspieler.
Ha.
Ich wusste es.
Respekt, Respekt Andreas.
Nee, was ich sagen will, ist folgendes, und zwar, also mir kommt das so vor, als ob Kolumbus einen Riesenfehler gemacht hat, als er Amerika entdeckt hat. Weil...
Vielleicht hat Amerika auch einen Fehler gemacht, als er Europa entdeckt hat, oder den Rest der Welt. Ich glaube, das ist eher das Anti-Eye des Kolumbus.
Gut, so kann man es aussehen. Weil, sei es der Bush, sei es der Bill, oder sei es auch wer auch immer, es kommt mir einfach so vor, als ob dieses Land immer mehr Macht an sich reißt. Ich meine, würde ich mir angucken, 95 Prozent, glaube ich, aller Rechner läuft auf Windows, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Die Statistiken kann man nicht so ernst nehmen, weil ich sag ja Microsoft nicht, hallo, ich hab grad Windows gelöscht, um Linux zu installieren. Also da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen. Aber es stimmt. Und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt persönlich, dass es eine große Schiene ist, um in Europa noch was zu reißen mit TCPA und Palladium. Weil im Moment sich hier so ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen Anti-Amerikanismus, aber doch so ein bisschen Sorge bereit macht, ob das nicht vielleicht ein bisschen weit geht, diese Vormachtstellung, die die Vereinigten Staaten aufbauen.
Diese totale Kontrolle des Users. Also wenn ich mir jetzt ein Windows Update ziehen will oder so, dann wird ja auch schon direkt eine eindeutige ID meines Rechners aus Mac Adresse und was weiß ich alles zusammengestellt, die mich dann ja wirklich eindeutig identifizierbar macht. Und das sind halt so, naja gut, das ist schon vielleicht der zweite Schritt. Die Seriennummer des Pentiums war der erste Schritt. Und so geht es halt immer weiter. Und dann landen wir wirklich da beim Big Brother Haus.
Also da gibt es ja schon Leute, die sich auch Gedanken über TCPA gemacht haben, wie das da laufen könnte. Und eine Sache war, also auch wenn das gar nicht schlecht oder bösartig gemeint ist, am Anfang so ein Schritt, der irgendwann kommt, ist das Synthology kommt und sagt, wenn sie mal hier Copyright und deswegen muss jetzt, und sagen wir mal, sie müssen das nicht in Europa machen, sondern in Amerika, die Fishman-Affidavit, das ist ein Beweismittel bei einem Prozess gewesen, der unter anderem weite Teile von dem auflegt, aufdeckt, was man eben bei Synthology sonst nur für echt viel Geld kriegt. Und das versuchen die seit Jahren aus dem Netz zu klagen und mit Anwälten. Und wenn jetzt Synthology irgendwann kommt und vor Gericht sagt, das ist unser Copyright, deswegen muss das vom Netz. In Amerika ist das traditionell einfacher. Und die würden dann per Gericht Microsoft veranlassen, die Prüfsumme von diesem Dokument in die Datenbank der schwarzen Listen aufzunehmen. Das wäre einfach mal weltweit gültig an der Stelle. Das heißt, es gibt durchaus, selbst wenn man sagt, das wollen die alles gar nicht, und die Amerikaner meinen das gar nicht so, und eigentlich sind die lieb und nett, das ist ja durchaus denkbar. Wir stellen uns ja auch nicht hin und sagen, die Amis sind die Bösen, die wollen uns alle platt machen. Aber selbst wenn sie das nicht böse meinen, das ist einfach eine Sache, die eines Tages passieren wird. Und wenn diese Erkenntnis bei gewissen Politikern und Lobbygruppen ankommt, dass man seine Konkurrenten und seine Greenpeace, wenn Greenpeace einfach so unter Druck gerät, dass ihre Presseerklärungen auf diese Art gefiltert werden können, da machen sie einfach Zensurmöglichkeiten breit, die sehr beängstigend sind. Selbst wenn man sagt, das ist eigentlich alles eine gut gemeinte Struktur. Es gibt ja so einen Spruch, die Straße zur Hölle ist gepflastert mit guten Vorsätzen. Die meiden das sicher alle gar nicht so böse. Auch der Senator Hollings, das ist im Grunde ein lieber alter Mann, der sitzt halt da in seinem Senatorenstuhl und dachte sich, er macht was für die lieben Hollywood-Leute, weil die ihr Arbeitsplätze schaffen. Also das ist alles gar nicht so schlecht gemeint, aber wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie da eine Eskalation stattfinden kann, wenn sich dann irgendwelche Parteien, die sich ja im Moment schon gegenseitig abhören, vielleicht ihre Dokumente gegenseitig sperren, also das ist schon sehr beängstigend, was technisch oder technologisch an der Stelle möglich würde. Und das ist auch einer der Hauptgründe, warum die Technologie im Grunde verhindert werden muss. Gar nicht mal das, was jetzt sofort konkret droht, sondern eben was langfristig möglich sein wird.
Na damit wären wir bei den Macht der Medien, nicht wahr?
Also Journalisten, die jetzt zuhören, bitte schreibt Berichte darüber. Macht andere Sendungen. Das muss ich halt rumsprechen. Ich meine, so ist das eben. Das ist ein Thema, das lässt sich nicht so mal eben in zwei Worten erklären. Aber es ist wichtig, dass man es trotzdem versucht, den anderen Leuten nahe zu bringen. Weil die meisten haben es einfach noch nie gehört und TCPA ist ja auch eine Abkürzung. Das klingt nicht so, als wenn es wichtig oder sexy wäre. Genau, es klingt nicht böse und trusted ist ja eigentlich auch eine gute Sache. Vielleicht sollten wir die Gelegenheit nutzen, zu sagen, warum es eigentlich trusted heißt.
Genau, und zwar hat das amerikanische Militär eine sehr schöne Definition für den Begriff trusted component, also vertrauenswürdige Komponente. Und zwar definieren sie eine vertrauenswürdige Komponente als ein Stück des Systems, das in der Lage ist, die Sicherheit des Gesamtsystems zu gefährden. Das klingt auf den ersten Blick natürlich erst mal absurd, aber wenn man einen Augenblick drüber nachdenkt, ist es genau die Komponente, wenn sie kaputt geht oder kompromittiert wird, dann geht halt das Gesamtsystem kaputt, also muss man ihr vertrauen. Und das wirft natürlich ein schönes Licht auf dieses Trusted.
Genau, das ist sozusagen die Firewall wäre eine Trusted Component. Denn wenn die kaputt geht, dann können Leute in dein Netz hacken. Das heißt nicht, dass du dem Firewall Hersteller vertraust, sondern du musst der Firewall an sich vertrauen. Denn wenn du ihr nicht vertraust, dann ist deine Gesamtsicherheit gefährdet. Deswegen heißt es Trusted, das heißt nicht, dass wir den vertrauen sollten oder dass auch die Implementierung vertrauenswürdig sein soll. Im Gegenteil, das heißt wir müssen ihnen vertrauen, denn wir haben gar keine Wahl. Das heißt wir sind nicht wir, der End-User, sondern wir, die Leute, die dieses System pushen. Und das sind nämlich Leute wie Intel und Microsoft. Deren Policy ist gefährdet, wenn TCPA versagt. Und deren Policy sagt, die Raubkopierer sind böse. Und die Linux-Kommunisten sind böse. Also das habe ich jetzt überschützt, das sagt Microsoft natürlich so direkt nicht. Aber das ist die Policy, die hier in Gefahr ist von diesem System. Nämlich nicht, dass ich als End-User, das ist meine Sicherheit, und die geht es überhaupt nicht, sondern es geht halt um die Sicherheit von den Leuten, die da TCPA in den Rechnern installieren wollen.
Warum soll ich denn einem großen Softwarekonzern vertrauen? Wäre es nicht viel klüger, den Usern an sich zu vertrauen? Ich meine, wenn ich den Statistiken glauben darf, als Napster geschlossen wurde, sind doch auch die CD-Verkaufszahlen eingebrochen.
Ist ja auch klar, ich meine, ist doch völlig logisch. Solange ich nicht einfach im Laden, wenn ich in den Laden gehe, kann ich mir eine CD anhören. Und kann sagen, okay, gut, das ist eine Sache, die ist in Deutschland etabliert, die gibt es auch in anderen Ländern, aber wenn ich da irgendwie feststelle, okay, nur das eine Lied, was ich im Radio gehört habe, war cool, und die 15 anderen waren alle scheiße, und die Schlange, einfach Vorweihnachtszeit im Moment, ist es echt schwierig, in so einem Laden mal eine CD reinzuhören, dann kann ich nicht hingehen und sagen, ich geb die zurück. Gab da gerade so einen besonders coolen Fall, da hat nämlich einer bei Amazon eine CD gekauft und hat die dann nicht abspielen können, weil die kopiergeschützt war. Ja, Moment, und dann hat er gesagt, okay, ich geb die zurück, weil ich die nicht abspielen kann. Dann hat Amazon gesagt, nein, nehmen wir nicht, weil das eine kopierbare Sache ist. Dann haben sie gesagt, hören Sie mal, ist kopiergeschützt, ist ja gerade das Problem. Dann hat Amazon gesagt, ja, gehen Sie doch mal ins Internet, da steht doch, wie man das doch kopieren kann. Also so sind die Leute im Moment drauf, dass einfach die Unsicherheit am Markt sehr groß ist und da muss man eben gucken, was man mit Aufklärung reißen kann. Also bei Trusted Computing geht es nicht darum, dass ihr dem Rechner vertraut, sondern im Gegenteil, dass der Reicher euch nicht vertraut.
Bitte, Andreas, immer mit Vergnügen.
Nein, nein, ich meine jetzt, das sollte für mich nicht vertrauen. Warum auch?
Ich meine...
Ja, ich böse User.
Du gibst denen doch nur Geld, die kennen dich doch gar nicht.
Andreas, vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Ja, besten Dank auch und noch eine gute Sendung.
Yo, tschüss, danke.
Tschüss, tschüss. Ja. Ja, eine Sache, die man noch anmerken sollte dazu, ist, dass natürlich die Techniker, die diese Sachen durchführen, für Microsoft, für Intel und so weiter und so fort, die stellen sich natürlich den Standpunkt, naja, ist doch nur Technik. Also wir machen doch da halt einfach nur coole Technik. Und was man dann dann hinterher damit anstellt, ist natürlich irgendwie, dafür können wir halt nichts. Also ist halt irgendwie ja halt so Technologie halt so zweckfrei. Und das ist auch bekannt in Amerika als die Werner von Braun Excuse. Und da gibt es ein sehr schönes Lied von Tom Lehrer. Das ist ganz kurz, das will ich gerade mal kurz spielen.
Und was ist es, das es möglich ist, 20 Billionen Dollar deines Geldes zu spenden, um einen Klang auf den Mond zu legen?
Wo kriegt man das?
Das hat mir Lucky gerade gebildet.
Gut, also alle schreiben Lucky.
Gibt es irgendwo eine Internetadresse?
Wir können das mal auf unseren FDP.
Ja, ich glaube wir können das einfach auf unseren FDP.
Und das heißt man trifft einfach vorbei bei http://chaosradio.ccc.de und da kann man sich das dann im Zweifelsfall downloaden, dieses wunderbare Lied. Das kann man wohl hinkriegen. Das wird in die Wigge geleitet. Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir haben es kurz nach zwölf und noch nicht nach bestehender Zeit zu talken und zwar zum Thema TCPA und das sei noch mal auseinander gefrickelt, Trusted Computing Platform Alliance, was so ein bisschen das ist, was eben die ganz Großen im Business der Computer, wie zum Beispiel Microsoft und Intel und Co. sich ausgedacht haben, was so als nächste Generation kommt und euch möglichst daran hindern soll, sowas wie CDs zu kopieren, DVDs und eben auch, naja, die Programme so ein bisschen mehr miteinander zusammenarbeiten lässt und zwar so nah zusammenarbeiten lässt, dass andere Programme mit denen gar nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten können. Das ist natürlich besonders toll. 0331 77 97 110, die Telefonnummer. Und ihr könnt auch mailen, wenn ihr am Thema teilnehmen möchtet, 78 at chaosradio.ccc.de ist die E-Mail-Adresse für Fragen und Hinweise zu eben dieser Sendung. 78 bitte als Zahl schreiben. Im Studio der Felix und der Frank vom Chaos Radio und meine Person Max von Malodki. Und wir machen einfach mal weiter, würde ich sagen, oder?
Ja, so ein bisschen Inhalt haben wir schon noch.
Wollt ihr erstmal noch mal so ein Stückchen vom Kuhn haben?
Ich würde gerne noch ein bisschen vom Kuhn haben. Felix, please. Genau, ein Detail vielleicht noch. Trusted Computing besonders gern, was Geeks ganz besonders gern machen, ist Abkürzungen, Zweck entfremden und einfach das T. Trustworthy bietet sich nun besonders an. Das Gegenteil davon ist Treacherous. Treacherous heißt, wie heißt das? Verräterisch. Genau, verräterisch. Also der Computer, der was anderes hinter meinem Rücken macht, als ich ihm gesagt habe. Und die Idee kam von Richard Stallman, der Mann, der die Free Software Foundation gegründet und das GNU-Projekt ins Leben gerufen hat. Und im Grunde hat er recht, finde ich. Also finde ich eine gute Abkürzung, wenn also jemand fragt, wofür denn TCPA wirklich steht. Deswegen ist die Treacherous Computing Plattform gut. Was wir hier noch vorbereitet haben, sind ein paar Argumente, die die Leute vielleicht bringen könnten, was wir uns gedacht haben, was die Leute vielleicht am Telefon sagen, was bisher noch nicht so kam. Also eine Sache kam schon, nämlich ja, Scheiß auf Windows, dann setze ich halt Linux ein. Wenn Windows was anderes macht, als ich ihm sage. Die TCPA sieht nicht nur vor, dass Software signiert wird, sondern eben auch Dokumente. Wir haben das schon so ein bisschen am Rand erwähnt, nach dem Motto, andere Leute Dokumente auf die Blacklist setzen. Das heißt aber auch, dass die Dokumente, selbst wenn sie nicht auf der Blacklist stehen, trotzdem verschlüsselt auf der Festplatte liegen. Nämlich mit dem Schlüssel der Anwendung. Und die Idee ist, dass man so natürlich dafür sorgen kann, dass Word perfekt, selbst wenn es auf derselben Plattform ist und selbst wenn es auch trustworthy ist, also auch signiert, dann kann es trotzdem die Word-Datei nicht mehr öffnen. Und das kommt zufällig gerade terminlich zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo Microsoft wegen der Dateiformate von einem Kartellrichter aufs Dach bekommen hat und wo sie anfangen, die nächste Word-Generation über XML zu sprechen, weil das ja so ein offener Standard ist. Also Reiner kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es ein Zufall ist. Microsoft selbst hat noch gar nicht gesagt, dass sie das tun wollen. Lucky hat das vorhin angesprochen, aber es liegt nahe.
Und was ist mit offenen Standards? Also XML wäre ja eigentlich ein offener Standard. Oder nehmen wir mal sowas wie PDF oder RTF oder irgendwas.
Na doch, es ist inzwischen auch ein offener Standard. Microsoft hat schon publiziert, wie die Office-Dateien aussehen, im Moment, weil sie halt den letzten Kartellrichter, der Vorgänger von der Frau Cotelli, der war ein bisschen schärfer drauf und den wollten sie damit beruhigen, dass sie das veröffentlicht haben. Und letztendlich gibt es ja inzwischen Software, wie z.B. OpenOffice oder StarOffice, die Commerzversion davon, mit der man unter Linux die Word-Dateien lesen und bearbeiten kann. Und durch TCPA wäre es eben möglich, dass die Dateien, obwohl Linux inzwischen so weit ist, dass es sowohl die DOS-Partitionen lesen kann, als auch die Word-Dateien, und sogar wenn es NTFS ist, ja, das kann Linux inzwischen lesen, und es gibt sogar Software, die diese Word-Dokument-Formate versteht. Trotzdem kann ich damit meine eigenen Word-Dateien nicht lesen, weil die ab jetzt verschlüsselt liegen. Also das ist schon so, dass man sagen kann, TCPA ist auch schon im Grunde mittelbar auf die freie Software-Community gemünzt. Denn was wir jetzt haben, ist ein Einweg-Kanal, eine Art Schleuse, die lässt es nämlich zu, dass ich von Windows aus auf Linux-Dateien zugreife. Wenn ich also, sagen wir, meine Word-Dateien mit Open Office unter Linux geschrieben habe, dann kann ich die mit Word normal schon öffnen. Aber umgekehrt eben nicht. Das heißt, Microsoft versucht durchaus, eben hier den Markt einzuschrecken. Und das ist eine Sache, Linux hat schon seit, hat von Anfang an im Grunde das Ziel gehabt, so möglichst eben den Leuten die Möglichkeit zu geben, ihre Dateien da zu editieren und eben auch kompatibel zu Windows zu sein. Und das wird eben, am Anfang hieß es, ja, Linux wird nicht performen, Linux wird nicht stabil sein, dann hieß es, Linux wird nicht skalieren, dann hieß es, es wird keine guten Anwendungen geben, es ist jetzt inzwischen alles umgefallen und im Grunde ist das das Letzte, was Microsoft jetzt noch tun kann, um Linux abzuschotten, ist eben gerade sowas wie TCPA. Und dementsprechend ist das Timing also sehr interessant an der Stelle.
Kommen wir doch nochmal zum Vergnügen, nachdem wir uns jetzt gerade wieder natürlich die Augen gerieben haben, vor lauter Schmerz. Lucky hört uns ja in den USA tatsächlich auch zu, mit dem wir vorhin telefoniert haben, der, der sich diese Software Licensing Part-Möglichkeit von TCPA hat patentieren lassen. Und der hat Frank das Lied geschickt, was wir gerade gehört haben. Und da er selber zuhört, möchte er einfach nochmal sagen, wo das Lied kommt.
It's by Tom Lehrer on a CD titled That Was the Year That Was. That Was the Year That Was, Tom Lehrer, L-E-H-R-E-R.
Okey dokey, thanks to America. Ach, fantastisch. Fantastisch.
Ist das Internet nicht großartig?
Es ist manchmal dann doch wieder fantastisch. Daher kommt die Musik und daher wird sie auch beantwortet, dass der liebte Sagen gerufen hat. Ja, zurück zum Thema.
Ja, also die nächste Sache, die wir uns überlegt hatten, ist, dann setze ich halt kein Word mehr ein. Wenn ich mit Word meine, wenn andere Leute meine mit Word geschriebenen Dateien nicht mehr öffnen kann, so, das wäre der nächste Schritt, dass die Leute halt sagen, okay, dann setze ich jetzt halt nur noch Linux ein und mache nur noch PDF als Dateiformat. Ist ja so, was man sich überlegen könnte. Und das kann auch nach hinten losgehen. Und ich habe mir hier ein Szenario überlegt, um das zu illustrieren, nehmen wir mal an, man ist ein Journalist. Ja, also ich bin jetzt ein Journalist und ich habe jetzt einen investigativen Report geschrieben über Microsoft. Nehmen wir mal an. Und ich habe da kriminelle Machenschaften aufgedeckt und gebe das jetzt zu meiner Redaktion weiter. Und die Redaktion schickt das Dokument zu Microsoft und sagt, machen sie doch mal einen Kommentar dazu. Und Microsoft kann dann einfach das PDF-Dokument nehmen, obwohl da überhaupt keine Microsoft-Software beteiligt war und kann die Signatur von diesem Dokument in die schwarze Liste eintragen. Und dann kann meine eigene Redaktion ihren eigenen Text nicht mehr lesen. Also TCPA betrifft nicht nur Software, sondern das kann noch ganz anders missbraucht werden. Und die Benutzung von Fire Software ist zwar gut, aber ist noch nicht hinreichend.
Die Frage ist ja dann auch, wer hat im Endeffekt die Macht, also dass Microsoft sich dann überlegt, was hätte es ganz gerne, wenn es dann mal gegen den eigenen Konzern geht oder nicht oder so. Das mag ja schon beeindruckend sein. Aber was ist denn, wenn zum Beispiel die NSA, CIA, FBI, BND, staatliche Institutionen, irgendwelche großen anderen Firmen, die auch mit diesem Trust enthalten sind, weil die sich auch überlegen, hey, dieses Dokument gefällt uns nicht. Ich meine, das könnte ja im Grunde auch dann sich immer weiter drehen, dass eben halt sehr, sehr viele die Macht haben, irgendwelche Dokumente zu sperren oder nicht.
Die Sperrung ist gar nicht so wichtig für die Bedarfsträger, sondern da ist erstmal wichtig, dass die an die Dokumente rankommen, auch wenn sie eigentlich TCPA-verschlüsselt auf meiner Platte liegen. Das heißt, es ist durchaus davon auszugeben, dass es Hintertüren gibt, um an die verschlüsselten Daten eben doch anzukommen, wenn man ein Bedarfsträger ist. Also das heißt, wir haben gerade die Geheimdienste oder Strafverfolgungsbehörden. Da steht natürlich in den Standards im Moment noch nichts drin, ja in den Papieren nichts gibt, aber da gibt es Gesetze für.
Also es ist ziemlich unwahrscheinlich, dass die Microsofter seinen Buddys aus der entsprechenden Branche nicht den Gefallen tut, diese Dinge einzubauen. Das haben sie in der Vergangenheit auch schon getan. Sie beteiligen zwar immer wieder, dass sie keine Backdoors irgendwo drin haben, aber es ist dann halt so die Sache mit dem Vertrauen.
Und jetzt haben wir ja Trusted Computing, jetzt wird ja alles besser.
Ihr könnt anrufen und euch an dem Thema beteiligen hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz033717797110 und einfach mit uns drüber reden, ob ihr sowas gut heißt oder nicht oder warum nicht zum Beispiel. Und am Telefon ist der Olaf, nannt Olaf. Der Olaf hat sich verabschiedet. Ich muss natürlich zugeben, dass wir zum Teil hier auch längere Klönpassagen einbauen. Und da kann es schon mal passieren, dass ihr ein bisschen länger warten müsst. Es tut uns umso mehr leid, wenn ihr dann eben halt am Endeffekt nicht mehr dran seid. Aber schauen wir mal, ob wir dem Hans jetzt einen Gefallen tun können.
Jo, der Felix hat gerade schon gesagt, also der CIA kann natürlich jetzt die verschlüsselten Dokumente lesen. Wahrscheinlich. Und das macht mir natürlich jetzt auch Sorgen, auch gerade wenn dann irgendwelche Staaten meinen TCPA als Gesetz durchbringen zu müssen, dass also jeder, der einen Computer sich kauft, gleich diesen TCPA mitkaufen muss, dass dann praktisch alles, was mit PGP, SSL etc. aufgebaut wird, dass das eigentlich hinfällig ist.
Nee, das ist ja nicht der Fall. Also worum es da geht, ist an der Stelle, dass die Verschlüsselung, die mit TCPA kommt, also die sozusagen von den meisten Usern verwendet werden wird, weil sozusagen mit dem System mitkommt, halt eine Hintertür haben wird. Wenn du darauf trotzdem noch ein eigenes Verschlüsselungsprogramm anwendest, also falls du das denn noch kannst, ist natürlich die interessante Frage.
Na, PGP ist schon ein gutes Stichwort, weil PGP wird nicht mehr kommerziell vertrieben im Moment. Ja, wenn ich das richtig weiß.
Nee, das ist nicht richtig. Es gibt die neue PGP Incorporated und die haben neue Betas von den PGP8 rausgebracht. Die sind ziemlich cool.
Achso, na gut. Ja, also aber trotzdem. Also was die meisten Leute einsetzen, ist eben irgendwelche alten PGP Versionen, nicht diese Betas. Und die sind selbstverständlich nicht signiert. Und viele Leute setzen bei Verschlüsselungssoftware die freien Varianten ein und nicht irgendwelche Kommerzsachen. Und das hat auch einen guten Grund. Denn wenn ich die Sourcen habe, dann habe ich überhaupt nur eine Chance zu gucken, ist da eine Hintertür drin oder nicht. Das heißt, es ist im Grunde sogar verpflichtend, bei Verschlüsselungssoftware nur Sachen einzusetzen, wo man den Quellcode hat. Und wenn die Sachen nicht verschlüsselt sind, dann können die natürlich die TCPA-geschützte Word-Datei nicht lesen. Das ist ja gerade die Idee bei TCPA, dass die dann eben noch mal extra verschlüsselt ist. Aber vielleicht sollten wir präventiv nochmal sagen, wir wissen auch nicht, wie das funktionieren wird mit dem Dokumentaustausch. Weil wenn die Dateien jetzt wirklich nur für Word verschlüsselt sind, dann kann ich die auch innerhalb von meiner Firma nicht mehr weitermählen. Also da wird schon irgendeine Variante geben, wie ich sagen kann, diese Datei soll jetzt eben unverschlüsselt rausgehen oder so. Nur wie das genau aussieht, weiß im Moment keiner.
Aber es kann jetzt natürlich auch jemand hingehen und sagen, ich setze jetzt alle PGP-Versionen, die kein Hintertürchen haben in der Verschlüsselung, setze ich auf die Blacklist. Und dann... PCP hinfällig. Unter Windows, klar. Wenn man dann sozusagen als kleine Gruppe sagt, ich setze jetzt nicht TCPA-konforme Hardware ein und tausche die Dokumente untereinander mit PGP und den freien Varianten aus, das wäre natürlich eine Variante, ist natürlich dann nicht mehr kompatibel mit der Masse.
Man muss sagen, dass das, womit TCPA steht und fällt, ist der Massendruck. Peer Pressure ist das halt nicht schön. Dass man sagt, die Leute haben Angst, dass ihre Wörttateien nicht gelesen werden können von anderen oder dass andere ihre Wörttateien nicht lesen können oder dass sie andere Leute Wörte und PowerPoint-Sachen nicht lesen können und deswegen trauen die Leute, sich nicht Linux einzusetzen. Das ist so das am häufigsten gehörte Argument. Letztendlich ist das der Hebel, an dem Microsofts Monopol im Moment hängt. Solang das so ist, dass die Leute Angst haben, dass sie Wörttokumente von anderen nicht öffnen können, werden die Leute Windows einsetzen und TCPA geht meines Erachtens in genau die Richtung, dass eben gesagt wird, ja mit Verschlüsselung und dann kannst du aber nicht ohne TCPA, weil sonst kannst du die Wörttateien von den anderen nicht öffnen. Und das ist genau das Argument, was bei näherem Hinsicht im Moment schon foot ist. 4 uncertainty doubt ist nur so ein Blar-Argument, um die Leute so in einer unkonkreten Angstsituation zu wiegen. Im Grunde ist es nicht so, dass man im Moment nur mit Wörttateien öffnen kann. Aber die TCPA-Initiative geht ja schon genau in die Richtung, diese Angst weiter zu schüren und deswegen glaube ich, dass das konkret eine Maßnahme ist, mit der Microsoft ihr Monopol aufrecht erhalten möchte. Vielleicht ein lustiges Detail dazu bei Microsoft ist, wegen dem 11. September müssen US-Firmen jetzt bessere, also umfangreichere Filings machen bei der Börsenaufsicht. Und da hat Microsoft unter anderem angeben müssen, welche Sparten wie viel Gewinn und wie viel Verlust machen. Und da ist rausgekommen, dass es überhaupt nur zwei Sparten gibt, die Gewinn machen. Das sind Windows und Office und alle anderen machen Millionenbeträge Verlust und zwar durchaus dreistellige Millionenbeträge. Und der Gewinnanteil ist auch mal bekannt gegeben worden, ganz fürchterlich peinlich, nämlich bei Windows 85% und bei Office 95% Gewinn. Das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Das ist ordentlich.
Genau, das ist also das Kerninteresse. Die können so viel Verlust machen, wie sie möchten, solange sie mit Windows und Office ihr Monopol aufrecht erhalten können, ist der Rest egal. Und deswegen ist das ihre Nummer 1 Priorität und ich glaube, das ist auch der eigentliche Grund hinter Palladium.
Irgendwo lebt Microsoft, denke ich mal, auch von Windows und Office. Also das ist auch ein ganz interessanter Marketingzug von Microsoft. Diese Firma versucht immer neue Technologien an den Markt zu bringen, fährt dabei erstmal eine ganze Weile Verlust ein. Und wenn die Technologien dann am Markt sich etabliert haben, dann werfen sie Gewinn ab. Und dann werfen die auch genug Gewinn ab, um die nächste Technologie zu finanzieren, die dann wieder Verlust einfährt, erst mal die ersten paar Jahre.
Ja, aber es gibt nicht viele Technologien, bei denen Microsoft im Moment Gewinn anfährt. Also im Grunde alles. Die Xbox macht riesen Verlust. Hier Windows CE ist wohl im Moment gerade dabei, in Break Even in die Nähe zu kommen. Aber so, die Embedded NT ist eingestampft worden. Was haben die noch alles probiert? Die haben versucht, in den Breitband-Internet-Markt zu gehen. Das ist ein kompletter Fehlschlag gewesen. Den Bank aufgemacht? Ja, seit ja gut. Das bei der Bank ist noch zu kurzfristig, um noch was zu sagen. Aber Microsoft macht im Grunde in fast allem Verlust, was sie tun, außer ihren Monopolteilen. Und deswegen ist es im Grunde auch das einzige, was für Microsoft wichtig ist, dass diese beiden Teile, nämlich Windows und Office, weiter Monopol bleiben. Denn wenn man denkt, dass die bei der Xbox, ich glaube, es waren 150 Millionen Dollar, einfach mal verpulvert haben, und die Xbox ist jetzt zwar gut im Markt, aber verkaufen sie immer noch mehr Playstations, obwohl da Microsoft drauf zahlt pro Konsole. Trotzdem können sie sich das einfach mal leisten und die können sich das ein paar Jahre lang leisten. Die haben sogar immer noch Gewinn, obwohl sie da rein powern. Und solange das so ist, letztendlich ist das der einzige Angriffspunkt, den Microsoft überhaupt hat, nämlich diese Windows- und Office-Monopole.
Ja, und da muss man dann halt zu sehen, dass man möglichst schnell eben die offenen Betriebssysteme fördert.
Ja, Leute aufklären. Lauft rum, zeigt den Leuten Open Office.
Ja, mach ich regelmäßig. Also ich setze Microsoft-Systeme hier nicht mehr ein.
Hans, vielen Dank, dass du angerufen hast.
Jo, bitte, bitte.
So, und am Telefon ist der Jörg aus Kamen.
Doch, Jörg.
Ja, wunderschönen guten Morgen.
Na, wind.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur ein bisschen was dazu erzählen, dass ich das interessiert verfolgen werde, weil ich persönlich der Meinung bin, dass es sich auf dem freien Markt überhaupt nicht durchsetzen wird, weil Monopolobi jetzt zum Beispiel Microsoft indirekt auch darauf aufbauen, auf diese Raubkopien und so was, weil momentan hat nun mal kaum jemand Geld und so eine Windows Version kosten auf Masche. Und ich wäre überhaupt nicht bereit, dafür irgendwie Geld auszugeben, weil ich bekomme halt nichts dafür. Und wenn das jetzt wirklich über TCPA gesichert werden würde, dass ich mir wirklich was kaufen muss, weil ich ja dann die Lizenz dafür haben muss, dann wird es richtig interessant, weil das tue ich ja nicht. Also entweder nutze ich dann alte Sachen, die dann eventuell auch wieder weiterverbreitet wurden, weil man neigt ja mal an Kollegen oder so. Also wird indirekt dann auch Open Source, beziehungsweise sämtliche Linux, FreeBSD und so ein Kram, gefördert. Und früher oder später, aufgrund der Lizenzen und TCPA, bin ich gern bei einem, werden wohl sehr viele User auf offene Systeme oder freie Systeme.
Aber glaubst du das wirklich?
Das sieht Microsoft genauso im Übrigen. Also man kann es ganz gut sehen. Microsoft, die haben gerade Bill Gates nach Indien geschickt. Dann hat er der Regierung erklärt, dass sie doch Windows einsetzen sollen. Und weil Bill Gates eingesehen hat, dass Indien pleite ist, weil sie nämlich ihr ganzes Geld in ihr Atomwaffenprogramm stecken, hat er ihnen mehrere, ich glaube sechsstellige Teile Windows-Lizenzen einfach verschenkt. Hat gesagt, ja, die Folgekosten, da reden wir dann drüber. Microsoft hat jetzt auch eine Bank gegründet kürzlich, mit der sie Kredite für Leute ausstellen, die damit ihre Software kaufen sollen. Also Microsoft sieht das ganz genauso. Die wissen, dass Windows und Office nur erfolgreich sind, weil die Leute an ihren Raubkopien zu Hause gelernt haben, wie man das bedient. Du kannst es ja nur lernen, wenn du die Software hast. Wenn jeder erst mal ein Jahr mit dem Manual verbringen würde, kannst du ja knicken. Also Microsoft ist völlig klar, dass sie von den Raubkopierern abhängt. Deswegen werden die Raubkopierer hauptsächlich in solchen Ländern verfolgt, wo Microsoft annimmt, dass man überhaupt was reißen kann. Und das sind eben die wohlverdienenden Länder, sowas wie Deutschland. Oder eben, jetzt auch ein bisschen Osteuropa ist jetzt auch ein bisschen im Gespräch, obwohl ich nicht glaube, dass da die große Kohle zu holen ist. Das ist glaube ich eher eine Marketing-Sache. Na ja, aber Microsoft weiß das.
Aber Windows ist ja im Grunde auch in der Regel umsonst, weil die meisten kaufen sich ja... Wer kauft sich schon Software einfach so? Die meisten kaufen sich einen Rechner. Und bei dem Rechner ist Windows dabei. Ja, aber das siehst du ja nicht.
Ja, es ist dabei, das ist aber was anderes.
Du kannst es ja nicht auseinanderfrickeln.
Da steht ja nicht, dass es den Windows davon kostet, sondern es ist einfach mal dabei. Und wenn du dann TCPA dabei hast, dann wirst du das auch benutzen wahrscheinlich.
Natürlich muss ich ja das benutzen, bin ich ja darauf angewiesen. Dann in dem Fall würde ich mir jetzt nur einen Rechner kaufen. Allerdings interessiert es den normalen User ja nicht Hauptsache, dass sein Word oder Powerpoint läuft, sondern dann ist das alles okay. Aber jetzt mal angenommen, wie gesagt, was ich mit den Daten war, er möchte seine Daten transportieren. Das wäre dann auch nicht mehr gegeben. Und auch wenn ich mich dahinter klemmen müsste, dass ich das da persönlich irgendwie umgehen kann oder sonst etwas nicht mehr zu tun, weil es einfach totaler Schwachsinn wäre. Aber wenn ich mir jetzt mal gucke, was Microsoft kostet und wenn unser Billy Boy keine andere Möglichkeit hat, außer die Lizenzen zu verschenken, damit halt sein Windows da irgendwo los wird, dann wird das auch noch richtig lustig aussehen bei den Leuten, die einfach kein Geld dafür haben, sich manchmal einen Service Pack oder ein Update zu kaufen. Und im Prinzip erübrigt sich dieses TCPA zumindest für so Betriebssysteme. Und das finde ich schon irgendwo interessant, weil was wollen sie da machen? Weil irgendwo lebt ja die Industrie von Wares und Raubkopien, was ich jetzt gerade eben auch gesagt hatte. Und wie wollen die das verwirklichen? Dass das wirklich so stabil läuft, auch für die ganzen User.
Na, Microsoft kann auch nicht in die Zukunft sein. Ich denke mal, die probieren es jetzt einfach mal. Microsoft hat übrigens in der Vergangenheit echt viele Sachen probiert, die voll nach hinten losgegangen sind. Also es ist nicht gesagt, dass das jetzt unbedingt funktionieren muss. Aber Microsoft hat halt die Kohle, um das zu machen. Und wie Lucky Green vorhin schon meinte, AMD hat keine Wahl gehabt bei den Prozessorerstellern. Die haben das halt gemacht. Und Apple hat gesagt, lass Microsoft die Hitze abkriegen. Das hat er gesagt. Let them take the heat. Also die Idee ist halt, die schlechte PR kann Microsoft über Jahre fressen. Die haben einfach Kunden, die gar nicht anders können als von ihnen zu kaufen. Und die kann man ärgern, solange man will. Klar kann man jetzt sagen, auch die User werden aber alle vergerollt werden. Das interessiert Microsoft gar nicht. Denn es gab ja immer noch diese ganzen Knebelverträge, das ging ja auch schon durch die Presse, dass eben der PC-Hersteller pro PC verkauft und nicht pro Windows-Lizenz an Microsoft abdrückt. Das war ein zentraler Punkt in dem Kartellverfahren gerade.
Was ich auch noch, also wo ich TCPA richtig interessant oder richtig gut finden würde, wäre zum Beispiel beim Server-Einsatz, wenn da jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwer meint, ok, ich spiele ja jetzt mit rum und installiere meinetwegen bei Microsoft einen freien FTP-Server im Public, das würde ja dann daraufhin nicht mehr gehen.
Wie, natürlich, der ist ja dabei, der ist ja signiert, das kann man schon machen.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt meinetwegen, ich programmiere mir jetzt hier einen kleinen FTP-Server, so und der wäre ja dann nicht signiert jetzt zum Beispiel für irgendeinen, keine Ahnung, für einen Mann wegen Netzgeld oder so, und ich breche dann alle, okay, ich verschaffe mir ohne erlaubten Zugriff und bin jetzt der Meinung, okay, ich möchte jetzt alle Development Tools und Source Codes alle da jetzt runterladen, installieren wir einen FTP-Server und das würde ja dann doch nicht gehen, oder? Aufgrund des TCPA, was ja nicht lizenziert, bzw. ja, zertifiziert ist.
Ja, aber auf dem Windows-Rechner gibt es ja da einen FTP-Client, der ist ja am Lieferumfang, kannst du also so kopieren. Also das ist nicht so das große Problem.
Es geht mir um den Server, um den Server-Sicherheit.
Ja, ne. Du brichst auf irgendeinen Server ein und willst die Daten da runterziehen, dann kannst du von dem Server aus FTP machen. Da musst du ja nicht auf dem Server entfernt irgendwie einen FTP-Server installieren.
Gut, sei zum Beispiel.
Ja, ja, ne, aber die meisten Beispiele kann man so. Weißt du, Microsofts Argumentation an der Stelle ist, wieso, bei uns ist doch ein FTP-Server dabei, der kostet gar nichts, der ist im Resource Pack. Microsoft macht das auch immer so, wenn irgendwie ein Markt sich entwickelt, dann machen sie ein Konkurrenzprodukt oder legen das kostenlos bei.
Jörg, das ist vielleicht auch was für ein Forumthread jetzt so in der Spezifizierung, ja? Also weil das ist ja schon jetzt ein sehr spezielles Problem, weil wir wollen jetzt auch ein bisschen Nachrichten machen und dank dir bis hierhin.
Na, und?
Na, und? Na, und?
Es ist dem Wetter, nachts ist es neblig, die Temperaturen sinken auf Gesundheit. 2 bis minus 2 Grad am Tag ist es dann bedeckt und trübe bei 4 bis 8 Grad und zu allem Überfluss gibt es dann auch noch und das kommt oben noch als kleines Bum-Bum-Bum drauf. Sprühregen! Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Hatschi-Börner.
Hatschi. Der frühere FDP-Spitzenpolitiker Jürgen Möllemann will seine Partei nicht freiwillig verlassen. Bei seinem ersten öffentlichen Auftritt seit Wochen warf er am Abend Teilen der FDP-Spitze mangelnde Fairness vor. Zugleich drohte er für den Fall seines Parteiausschlusses mit der Gründung einer neuen liberalen Partei. Die Bundesregierung hat es abgelehnt, die USA im Falle eines Irakkrieges mit Waffensystemen zu unterstützen. Nach einem Treffen mit den Vorsitzenden der Bundestagsfraktion sagte Bundeskanzler Schröder, Deutschland werde den USA und den NATO-Partnern Überflugrechte und den Transit von Truppen gewähren. Zum Auftakt ihrer Mission untersuchten die UN-Waffenkontrolleure heute zwei Militäranlagen und eine Fabrik in der Nähe der Hauptstadt Bagdad. Über den Verlauf der Untersuchungen äußerten sie sich anschließend zufrieden. Irakischen Behörden hätten Zusammenarbeit demonstriert und die Arbeit nicht behindert. Die islamistische Vereinigung Kali Fadz-Stadt bleibt verboten. Das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig bestätigte am Abend eine Entscheidung der Bundesregierung. Die radikale islamische Organisation wurde von Bundesinnenminister Schili im Dezember 2001 verboten. Und zum Sport in der Zwischenrunde der Fußball Champions League hat Bayer Leverkusen gegen den FC Barcelona 1 zu 2 verloren.
Ich kann mit geschlossenen Augen gleichzeitig 5 übereinander versteckte Hemdkragenaufdrucke in einem Vakuumkanister jonglieren.
Und Sie? Ich kann mit den Füßen Klavier spielen. Und Sie?
Ich kann ganz doll schielen.
So.
Fritz präsentiert die ungewöhnlichste Show des Jahres.
Der Star will ich.
Die außergewöhnlichsten Talente von hier und aus der Gegend. Auf der Bühne der Arena Treptow in Berlin. Samstag, 14. Dezember, 19 Uhr. Moderiert von Radio Fritz und Oliver Klein. Und wenn auch du glaubst ein Talent zu sein, dann komm zum Casting. Sonntag, zwischen 11 und 19 Uhr in der Arena Treptow.
Ich kann auch Arschbombe.
Und im Radio Fritz.
Ihr hört den Blue Moon auf, Fritz. Chaosradio. Noch 20 Minuten. Es geht um TCPA. Die Zukunft vom Windows Betriebssystem in Zusammenarbeit mit Hardware-Komponenten, also sowas wie Intel, Grafikkarten, Boards, weißt der Teufel, was da noch alles dran hängt, um zu ermöglichen, dass es eine sichere Plattform wird, insofern sicher, dass sich Microsoft sicher sein kann, dass dann nur noch damit gearbeitet wird und bloß kein Austausch stattfindet. Dvds und CDs und so weiter nicht mehr kopiert werden können. Soweit nochmal die Erklärung in Kürze, worum es sich dabei handelt und wo man, wenn man kann, einfach sich ein bisschen gegenwehren sollte. Chaosradio Team besteht heute aus Felix und Frank und meiner Wenigkeit als helfenden Host zu sagen Max von Malodki. Und am Telefon ist der Stefan. Hallo Stefan. Nee, der hat die Musik auch genutzt ins Bett zu gehen. Kann man auch verstehen, ist schon relativ spät. Aber der Alex ist am Telefon. Alex, n'Amt. Deine Meinung zu TCPA?
Na ja, erst mal muss es ja nicht unbedingt schlecht sein, wenn man da eine Hardware hat, die nicht jeden Mist gleich ausführt, nur weil er Punkt-Exe ein.
Das macht aber das System, die Hardware ausführen. Punkt-Exe wird bei mir zum Beispiel nicht ausgeführt. Da muss ich mich echt anstrengen, damit Unterlienungspunkte extra ausgeführt werden.
Du meinst, das wäre praktisch, in so einem doch ziemlich löchrigen und immer roten System wie so einem PC ein bisschen Vertrauenswürdigkeit und Sicherheit zu haben.
Weißt du wenigstens, dass deine Version vom Internet Explorer von Microsoft signiert wurde? Das Problem ist ja, dass die Signaturen nicht verhindert, dass da Lücken drin sind. Du weißt dann zwar, dass nur die von Microsoft drin sind, aber das ist ja nicht wirklich beruhigend, wenn man sich das in ihrer Historie ansieht. Also ich halte das für einen echten Fehlschluss daraus zu schließen, dass man jetzt nur noch sichere Software hat. Microsoft, ich meine, die haben in den letzten Monaten versucht Bugs zu fixen und von den Invisories ist nicht eins gewesen, was sie intern gefunden haben, sondern alles extern reingereicht.
Muss es denn unbedingt Microsoft sein, die weder den endgültigen Daumen drauf haben, welche Software unsigniert sein darf und welche nicht. Es gibt letztendlich ein Problem von einer Public Key Infrastruktur oder sowas, wo das Vertrauen eigentlich herkommt. Und die ganze TCPA Hardware, die sorgt ja nur dafür, dass das auch durchgesetzt wird.
Also du meinst, es wäre alles nicht so schlimm, wenn man dann sicherstellen könnte, dass die Signing Keys nicht in den Händen von Microsoft sind, sondern es irgendwie zumindest so ein halböffentlicher oder gar öffentlicher Weg ist. Nur die Frage ist, wem willst du denn genau diese Verantwortung geben zu entscheiden, welches Software zu trust du hast, die ist und welche nicht? Also ich meine, letztendlich ist das ein bisschen schwierig. Es ist also genauso unpraktisch wie diese Entscheidung, wem man jetzt die Verantwortung für was zensiert werden soll und was nicht zensiert werden soll, geben soll.
Wem gebe ich denn heute die Verantwortung, welche Software ich auf meinem Rechner laufe?
Na, die hast nur du selbst.
Ja, wenn ich völlig aufpasse, dass ich mir da nicht irgendwo ein Virus und so weiter einfange. Und ich weiß nicht, wäre schon ganz gut, wenn die Hardware einen da ein bisschen bei unterstützen könnte.
Na, das tut sie doch aber nicht. Wie kommst du denn darauf, dass ein Virus ein eigenes Programm sein muss? Ein Virus kann auch in Form von einem Wurm auf dein Rechner kommen und denen da fühlst du gar nichts aus. Dass irgendeiner greift dich an, benutzt irgendeinen Buffer-Overflow und irgendeine Software, die bei dir läuft, also dass die Hardware dich vor Viren schützt, das ist auf keinen Fall der Fall, das kann man ja schon sagen. Ja, und das geht ja noch weiter, also der eigentliche Hammer, den wir uns hier vorhin beim Essen überlegt haben, ist, dass ja TCPA zwingt, dass alle Leute die gleichen Updates eingefahren haben. Ja, und das heißt, dass die Monokultur noch viel stärker ist als im Moment. Das wird also viel einfacher sein, neue Viren für ein System zu schreiben, weil die nicht mehr irgendwie portabel sein müssen, sondern ich kann einfach das Offset ablesen, wie es im Moment ist, trage das in meinen Exploit ein, der läuft dann auf allen Windows-Kisten. Also es wird eher unsicherer durch TCPA.
Na gut, erzwungene Updates sind natürlich... Da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es auch eine Menge große Kunden gibt, die das nicht haben wollen. Das ist eine große Firma, die will ja auf all ihren Rechnungen die gleiche Software laufen haben. Und bevor da irgendjemand ein Update einspielt, oder auch die Benutzer anfangen sich da MP3s und so etwas mit Spaß drauf zu erlauben, will der am liebsten der Admin immer erst das vorher prüfen können. Und da könnte so ein System ja eigentlich auch helfen, aber da muss man natürlich aufpassen, dass da nicht wieder zu viel automatisch passiert. Und ja, wer halt wirklich da nun das darüber bestimmt?
Ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, aber wir hatten ja darüber gesprochen und das als Worst-Case-Szenario hingestellt, dass sich die amerikanische Regierung eben sogar dahinter klemmt und das Ganze gesetzlich festlegt, dass sowas auf einem Computer vorhanden sein muss, ist es dann aber nicht wahrscheinlich, dass die Regierung auch so weit gehen möchte, das Ganze dann gesetzlich so weit festzulegen, dass sie sagt, wir hätten auch gerne den Daumen drauf, informen irgendeiner Behörde. Die werden doch nicht Microsoft das auch noch dann anheim geben. Ich nehme mal nicht an, dass das passieren wird, oder?
Na ja, gut, da kann man natürlich viel drüber spekulieren. Also wenn man sich da dieses tolle Office für Homeland Security anguckt, dann könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass sie gerne irgendwie auch das Homeland auf den heimatlichen Computer einsichern wollen. Aber das ist Spekulation, da kann man wenig zu sagen.
Schade.
Der Alex ist auch schon wieder total zerknirscht.
Die macht die Leute immer so fertig. Das geht überhaupt nicht.
Wir gehen immer nach Hause und sind uns so gut dran.
Wir sind auch schon ganz traurig.
Na ja, kommen wir mal zu Milos.
Hallo Milos.
Hallo. Ich entwickle mit ein paar Leuten zusammen eine Xbox-Linux-Version. Und bei der Gelegenheit haben wir uns das Sicherheitssystem von der Xbox genau angeschaut. Und da haben wir sehr früh ziemlich Probleme gehabt, überhaupt irgendwas drauf zu laufen zu bringen. Und was wir inzwischen sehen, also die Xbox scheint zu einem Testballon von Microsoft zu sein, um ihr TCPA zu testen. Erstmal von Akzeptanz her. Da scheint sich erstmal niemand darüber beschwert zu haben. Und zweit, was wir gesehen haben, es ermöglicht, dass praktisch andere Betriebssysteme verboten werden. Also was wir langsam befürchten, dass sich das erstmal durchsetzen könnte und ein PC einfach kein Stempelmessel kommt. Okay, das ist einfach Windows. Und jeder Hersteller letztendlich eine Sperre einbaut, in der nicht zugelassene Betriebssysteme einfach nicht ausgeführt werden können. Und dieser Schutz ist halt nicht einfach dadurch zu überlüsten, dass man eine andere Floppy oder sowas einsteckt. Sondern das greift halt direkt im Chipsatz drin. Und es verhindert praktisch schon einfach, selbst wenn man das BIOS flashen könnte, selbst mit einem externen Gerät, dass man überhaupt irgendwas anderes ausführt. Und das glaube ich, wird ein echtes Problem werden in Zukunft.
Das ist bei der Playstation im Übrigen ähnlich. Da gibt es eigentlich Linux von Sony. Und da kann man nur genau dieses Linux einsetzen. Da gibt es also nicht irgendwie, ich compile mir mal meinen Kernel selbst, sondern genau diesen Kernel und genau der läuft dann. Und das klingt zwar wie Linux, hier toll, open source, freie Software, aber weit gefehlt. Also Microsoft ist zwar vorne an der Front dabei, aber sie sind nicht die einzigen.
Hier ist Sony, hat es relativ clever gemacht. Die haben ja nicht wie Microsoft angefangen, einen Browser zu entwickeln für ihren ganzen online Schisslmesseldienst, sondern die haben das Ding eben halt deswegen freigegeben, weil sie erwarten, dass der open source Community diese ganzen Grundarbeit macht und die ganzen Bugs rausarbeitet. Und dann setzen die sich halt auf so ein semi open source System oben drauf und nehmen dann den Browser. Das ist nämlich genau das, was sie vorhaben. Das haben die sogar gesagt.
Ja, frech. Kannst du noch ein bisschen was dazu sagen, was sie da so für Sicherheitsmaßnahmen in der Xbox verwendet haben, um an Leute daran zu hindern, andere Kernel darauf zu booten?
Also das Dumme daran ist, dass es nicht mehr wirklich teuer ist. Also die erste Hürde ist die praktisch im Shipsatz, wird praktisch an den Anfang des BIOS, oder an die Stelle, an der der Prozessor einspringen würde, werden 512 Bytes Code eingeblendet. Und dieser überprüft praktisch, ob das BIOS die richtige Prüfzumme hat und ob es signiert ist. Und erst dann führt das BIOS aus. Das entpackt sich wiederum, prüft sich selbst und so weiter. Und irgendwo kommt die Stelle, wo von der Festplatte dann dieses Dashboard nachgeladen wird. Das wiederum ist auch signiert. Und es wird praktisch nichts. Also es ist nur wirklich eine geschlossene Kette. Wir haben es wirklich einfach nur doodle zu verdanken, dass es einfach läuft. Wir haben jetzt nicht irgendwie eine super tolle Lücke gefunden, die man schwer schließen könnte, sondern ein scheinbar Hintertürchen des Grafikkartenherstellers, das uns ermöglicht, überhaupt irgendwas auszuführen. Und so wie es aussieht, ist es halt nicht wirklich teuer. 512 breite Masken-ROM irgendwo in den Chips reinzumachen, das ist halt nicht wirklich Raketentechnik.
Was ich besonders cool dabei fand, ist, dass ja an der Stelle schon auch in dem ROM, also in dem eigentlichen BIOS, Daten stehen. Also dass es schon so eine Art Verwirrungsaktion war. Dass nämlich der eigentliche Angreifer sich halt natürlich das BIOS anfindet, da Kurs. Und selbst wenn er den ändert, wird er halt nicht ausgeführt. Also die haben schon, das ist schon was lustiges.
Also das habe ich auch entdeckt. Und naja, man kann jetzt sagen, okay, so wie es jetzt ist, ist es noch nicht wirklich wild, weil es wird zum Beispiel halt keine Public Key Signatur überprüft, sondern es ist ein relativ simpler Prüfstum-Alborithmus, bei der halt auf 512s Breit beschränkt ist. Aber das Problem ist, es ist halt wirklich sicher machbar. Also man macht da dieses ROM ein bisschen größer, aber es ist halt wirklich möglich. Und bis jetzt hat sich auch niemand wirklich darum beschwert, dass er letztendlich auf eine leicht abgewandte PC-Architektur nichts anderes drauf laufen lassen kann, als das was Microsoft gibt. Und Microsoft scheint sich auch rechtlich ziemlich gut durchzuboxen und hat auch ein paar große Mod-Chip-Herschen einfach Zeit gemacht. Also die haben das schon richtig gut in der Hand. Und ich denke mal, die sammeln jetzt halt Erfahrungen und bis jetzt scheint es anzukommen einfach. Und wenn dann der PC dann halt, sag ich mal, von Euro billiger sein wird, das wird einfach kommen.
Und was für Auswirkungen hat das auf die Szene?
Also wir haben da ein ganz großes Problem. Also das macht uns richtig mächtig Sorgen. Also wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, ja wer knackt praktisch Xbox? In Anführungszeichen. Dann sieht man, okay, hauptsächlich Europäer. Und sagt man dann von mir, das Amerikaner sind doof. Aber stimmt das einfach nicht. Also wir haben halt, einiges Amerikaner, die haben halt einen Schiff praktisch damit, offenen Namen aufzupreten. Die arbeiten damit. Aber denen ist ganz klar, dass wir halt dafür verknackt werden können. Genau. Und halt in Europa. Wegen was? Wir sehen mal das gleiche. Jetzt im Dezember wird ja diese EU-DMCA durchgesetzt. Und dann wissen wir auch nicht, was weiter geht. Also irgendwie die einzigen Leute, die irgendwie, also ja ja, es ist für die Leute ein echtes Problem, jetzt fahren weiter zu arbeiten, weil sie langsam muss ein tausend bekommen einfach.
Digital Copyright Millennium Act ist ein Gesetz aus 1998 in den USA, wo drin steht, dass man Kopierschutzmaßnahmen nicht umgehen darf, selbst wenn die selbst nicht rechtens waren. Also wenn sozusagen man eine Kopiergeschützte CD kauft und eigentlich das Recht hat, sie zu kopieren, dann darf man den Kopierschutz nicht umgehen. Das heißt letztendlich, es ist dem Gesetzgeber nicht gelungen, die Erlaubnis für das Kopieren selbst wegzunehmen. Das haben sie auch mehrfach versucht. Und so haben sie das halt durch die Hintertür über diese technische, naja, ich will nicht sagen, Lendaktion haben sie das halt implementiert. Prickelnd. Ganz toll. Und Europa, wie gesagt, arbeitet auch daran.
Ja, und wenn ihr das richtig verstanden habt, wird jetzt praktisch Mitte Dezember, muss die Regelung in Deutschland auch umgesetzt werden. Also vor zwei Jahren ist es ungefähr durchgelaufen. Die zwei Jahre sind jetzt fast rum. Und jetzt im Dezember irgendwie, Mitte Dezember, müsste es in Deutschland eigentlich auch gültig werden.
Ich glaube, es war erst mal nur eine Empfehlung und noch keiner.
Also soweit ich gelesen hab, steht drin. Also innerhalb von zwei Jahren muss es durchgesetzt sein. Und das läuft jetzt Mitte Dezember ab. Und die Formulierung da drin kann man schon ein bisschen Spanisch vor. Letztendlich steht da leicht, ja, so mal euphemistisch beschrieben, Ausgleiche drin. Also sobald ich praktisch irgendeine Hardware, wir haben ja die Chemikie, die, oder als Deckentfremde, die nicht vom Hersteller vorgesehen ist, kann ich da auch Probleme kriegen. Gut, man muss natürlich da halt auf den Prozess ankommen lassen, aber genau da verlieren wir unsere Leute. Weil andere Leute, manche Leute haben halt überall ihr Hobby, da halt nicht unbedingt erworsten, dass sich jetzt durch irgendeinen Musterprozess durch den Boxen.
Gut, das ist auch eine Sache, da können wir jetzt im Nachhinein nicht mehr so viel machen, aber wenn wir es schaffen, ein genügend großes Movement hier zu erzeugen, Leute, die ihre EU-Abgeordneten in den Hintern treten, dann ist es schon durchaus möglich, ein Gesetz auch wieder rauszuschmeißen. Also, es muss nur gemacht werden. Ich sag das jetzt... Ja, das kann natürlich auch passieren. Das ist ja die beste Variante, dass ein Gericht kommt und sagt, das ganze Gesetz ist nicht verfassungsgemäß oder bla. Nur das Problem ist, historisch, wenn sowas passiert, dass die halt ein anderes Gesetz bringen, was im Grunde das Gleiche sagt, ein bisschen anders formuliert. Das wird dann durch die Hintertür gemacht. Das ist in Europa glücklicherweise nicht so krass wie in Amerika. Da kommt es durchaus vor, dass in einem Gesetz zur, was weiß ich, Postzustellungsverordnung, da wird dann irgendwie nebenbei erwähnt, dass sie eben, was weiß ich, ganz andere Gesetze über, dass eben sowas wie die MCA, ist schon durchaus passiert, dass dann auf dem Gesetz drauf stand, wir regeln hier, was weiß ich, den Tiefgang von maritimen Gefährten und dann innen drin stand irgendwas wie Kopierschutz umgehend verboten.
Das heißt dann im dortigen Sprachgebuch Omnibus.
Also wenn man auf zukünftige Hardware Linux laufen haben will, dann wird man wahrscheinlich sich von vielen Komponenten einfach fatschieren müssen. Also zum Beispiel eine Soundkarte wird man dann nicht. Ohne das Problem werden, das hat Linux zumindest mal nur stark eingeschränkt, nutzbar sein wird auf dem TCPA Computer.
Miloš, da können wir leider nur mitseufzen und hoffen, dass ihr möglichst lange weitermacht und immer noch Leute aktivieren könnt, die sich eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr trauen. Vielen Dank, dass du angerufen hast. Ja, das war es schon wieder mit dem Chaosradio, mit dem Blumen auf Ritz. Wir haben es nämlich kurz vor eins und hoffen, wir haben so ein bisschen die Augen geöffnet. Also ich hätte schon mal wieder so aus dem Halbschlaf gerissen. Auf jeden Fall muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben. Danke Felix, danke Frank und danke mir. Jetzt gibt es den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Und ich denke mal, es gibt bestimmt noch Kommentierungsbedarf und Nachlesebedarf und ähnliches Informationen, Entweige Lieder und Zusammenfassungsansätze wird es geben unter http://chaosradio.ccc.de Und ihr könnt eine Mail schicken, wenn ihr euch für diese Sendung interessiert, an 78 als Zahl geschrieben, also 7 und 8, at chaosradio.ccc.de Und damit verabschieden sich der Felix. Der Frank. Und der Max. Viel Spaß beim Night Flight.